this is Jocko podcast number 404 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening we talk a lot
about the path
and we do know what the path is
generally speaking
the path of discipline
the path is doing the right things for
the right reasons the path is long-term
strategic thinking
and
delayed gratification
instead of short-term thinking and
instant gratification
the path is taking care of other people
the path is being humble the path is
being balanced
and being on the path capital T capital
p
leads us down the path of Our Lives
in our decisions impact what we do where
we end up and when we Stray From the
Path
our life is negatively impacted but when
we stay on the path
the positive results over time will come
now of course there's no guarantees
life gets a vote
chance gets a vote
there is such a thing as bad luck
we cannot anticipate everything there
are some things that are actually beyond
our control
and when those things occur we take
ownership of how we respond and we learn
from the good from the bad from the ugly
we learn
and tonight we have with us a friend of
mine who has learned a lot
his name is Sean glass he's a former
seal officer a combat veteran with tours
in Iraq and Afghanistan
he taught leadership and the SEAL Teams
he's also LED in the business World
working in a startup and then starting
his own startup
he's
a husband a father a leadership
instructor at Echelon front and he's
here with us tonight to share some of
his experiences and lessons learned
about leadership and life
thanks for coming down man thanks for
joining us appreciate you having me
what'd I miss did I miss anything on
your intro
yeah and then you were in business
your dad what do you got five kids five
kids as of now time now yeah Jack we're
still working still time yeah I'm young
yeah I like it my wife was at tapped out
at four
yep she told me no more
yeah we're at five currently which uh my
wife's one of eight so she's no so she's
down for the call she's down for the
cause yeah yeah yeah that's legit right
on all right we'll keep our fingers
crossed all right let's start at the
beginning let's start where you came
from let's see how you got here where
did where did it all start where are you
born so I grew up uh in a small town in
Texas I tell people the town is called
Corsicana because that's the only town
that is big enough that people might
actually recognize on a map if they're
familiar with Texas but I did not
actually live in Corsicana Corsicana was
where we did School sports stuff like
that but I lived on a small ranch in a
town called Blooming Grove and I didn't
really even live in Blooming Grove we
were literally just out in the middle of
nowhere what there was no name for your
it was literally no name Uncharted my
road didn't even have a name my room was
my road was called Farm Road 1390 like
they just ran out of names basically
they started numbering them just started
let's put a number on it because
literally no one cares about this road
out there so the nearest town to me he
was a town called Berry and it had like
73 people total population so we had 60
Acres had a small little ranch operation
out there but we lived about 20 minutes
outside of town so very rural and the
town is the town with 73 people the town
is Corsicana is the the town and is that
where you had to go get groceries and
whatnot groceries School sports
gasoline all that stuff was Corsicana so
you're in the middle of nowhere
literally in the middle of nowhere yeah
yeah and what did your dad do so my dad
was a entrepreneur him and his brother
started company they had a bunch of
different stuff going on throughout
their their lives but uh
um when I was young their main thing was
they had some barber shops that they
opened up all throughout Texas totally
random they always dabbled in real
estate they ran or my dad ran horses on
the ranch for a little bit just kind of
cereal entrepreneur trying all kinds of
different stuff out but probably the
consistency was real estate always kind
of buying and selling real estate you
know my dad
was an entrepreneur
allegedly
my dad's success with business was
horrible yeah like he would start
businesses and we would just lose money
like our family would lose money and go
in the hole and it was just terrible I'm
surprised I've ever tried any business
at all because I was kind of mentally
scarred I'd see my dad like start
businesses and put money into him and
remortgage stuff and all of a sudden it
could all be gone yeah I'll be gone I'm
sure there was some of that stuff going
on we had lots of horses and then one
day we had not lots of horses so I'm
sure there was some of that stuff that
happened but I'm sure they were also
trying to keep some of that stuff from
us but I mean what about the barber
shops yeah they I think there's still
one maybe that's still up and running
out of the seven I think that they
started but we always had food on the
table you know he always provided super
hard worker you know we always made sure
that we were provided for for sure but
some Ventures more successful than than
others you know uh Echo and I talk about
like when you when you get an idea and
you're going to start a business right
you go get a URL right back in the day
you didn't get a URL because there was
no internet so my dad would have like go
get business cards made yeah yeah so
you'd get like these business cards made
for like the new business thing and like
that's you know we'd have 10 years later
we just have like a box of business
cards his name and the business name and
yeah and like a big debt yeah luckily
look luckily for me and my family my dad
was doing all this on the side you know
what I mean because he had to use a
school teacher my mom was a school
teacher so he would take chances I guess
with some of the some of the you know
money from his regular job but just none
of it ever panned out so yeah it was
kind of a bummer but he wasn't even
trying any barber shops or anything like
that I think that's worth the money is
really is the barber shop yeah
uh and what about your mom uh she was a
teacher so okay yeah so she started off
as a medical laboratory technologist I
think or technician so she was working
in Hospital doing Labs all kinds of
stuff and then when we were born she
wanted to be home with us so she took a
step back from that and started teaching
so all throughout growing up that's all
I knew was that she was a teacher what
grades did she teach so she taught when
we went to our elementary school she was
working there at the elementary school
teaching High School science at first
and then we had a junior college in our
town Corsicana called in the Vero
College which shout out to Navarro
College if you've ever watched which I'm
sure you have not the show about
cheerleading on Netflix that's Navarro
Navarro College was known for their
nationally recognizable Championship
cheerleading squad damn So eventually
she made the transit eventually being
our school shut down and then she
transferred over to the college and
taught there for I want to say like 20
25 years and then just retired two years
ago okay right on and you said we
meaning the kids would you have for
brothers sisters all right two sisters
one older sister after two years and one
younger sister by two years yeah so
that's the same pattern as I am I got
one older sister one younger singer
we're all about two years apart yeah we
all close growing up
I don't know I mean say I'm not sure
um
I think we're probably we we we yeah we
were fine you know but we were all a lot
different you know what I mean so there
wasn't a lot of you know there wasn't a
lot of hanging out I guess yeah I'd say
same here very different I think we're
closer now than we ever were I would say
I would say we are too yeah plus I think
I was a real kind of an I was
not the best brother for sure yeah if
you can talk to my little sister there's
definitely some emotional scarring and
horror stories I think my older sister
uh hates me hated me more than my
younger sister I was kind of like cooler
to my younger so I was pretty pretty
much an to my older sister
sometimes but then we all we also hung
out we also had like a group of friends
together so I don't know I guess it was
I guess it would be about average sounds
like it's about the same as yours which
means we're doing about the same thing
and then so what are you doing you're
what are you doing for like fun how old
are you what are you doing so we had UH
60 Acres which when you're a kid you
know I live on 60 Acres now in Virginia
and it's a good piece of land for sure
but it's not you know a national forest
or anything like that but when you're
five or six or ten years old I mean 60
Acres seems like a vast Wilderness so oh
yeah I was outside we like I said we
lived in the middle of nowhere so when
our day would basically be you'd wake up
you'd take care of the animals you go to
school if you had Sports you know you do
your sports and then when it came time
to come home like that was it for the
night you weren't doing anything else
you're not going back into town because
you forgot something so a lot of time
just roaming around the property and our
property was probably
60 65 percent woods and then the rest
was pasture so I would just disappear
into the woods and you know pretend like
I was a cowboy or a soldier and just
wreak havoc and for a time a very short
time my cousins lived next door relative
next door right like they're you know a
half mile down the road basically next
piece of property but uh we would link
up and just run amok in the in the
wilderness basically did you have any
water features we did so we had uh some
ponds for the livestock and then we also
had when it would rain we had a pretty
good sized Little Creek that ran through
the woods and that to me was the the
coolest thing my dad built a little
bridge out of railroad ties across the
the water for us and I mean we thought
we were like in the jungle when we were
back there yeah Texas is weird though
because they count a Dry Creek as a
creek yeah it's dry 90 yeah like I look
at real estate in Texas it's like oh
Creek and I'll look at pictures it's a
freaking day yeah that's right yeah
the key word you want to look for for
Texas water features live live water
yeah live water so you're out there
running around did you have guns yeah so
I had uh BB guns at first so like my
parents
dad did not grow up in the country so he
moved us all out there to give us that
type of life but he grew up in a city
his parents were both musicians they
played in orchestras all across the
country they played in the Dallas
Orchestra when he was uh growing up so
like you know did not have the rural
existence like we did so not a lot of
familiarity with guns but we had the 22s
and stuff like that and he would take us
out there shooting and then we always
had our BB guns and then when I became a
little bit older you know 1617 you got
the shotgun running around the property
and whatnot but mostly BB guns and
pellet guns and whatnot and then you
have to go to 20 minutes to get to
school yep and what you going to public
school so what are you doing we went to
a small Christian School in Corsicana
that was started by about the time that
we started being school-aged as kids a
bunch of parents got together and
started this as kind of an alternative
basically to the the public school
there's just not a lot of choice there
it's either the public school or you
were going to uh this one privacy what's
the population Corsicana when I was a
kid probably like 21 22 000 I think it's
sitting around like 30 000 right now or
something like that but it's a decent
sized we had a Walmart at a time and had
a Kmart before it came out ran out of
business so when I was a kid that was
like big time having a Kmart in a
Walmart so yeah yeah about 20 000 lots
of Christmas shopping got done at Kmart
oh yeah yeah they got that Blue Light
Special
yeah oh yeah oh that was the deal so we
went to that small school and it was an
interesting experience because it was
kind of a blend of
probably parents who are very
like-minded and wanting to teach their
kids you know the things that Faith
aspect of life and then because it was
the only other school in town if you got
booted out of the public school you were
going to the the small Christian School
so it was a hellions it was a blend of
learning that happened at uh Corsicana
Christian Academy for sure and are you
playing sports I was playing sports but
again it was it was pretty selective
just based off of the population of that
school so we didn't have enough to feel
the football team or anything like that
so it was basically soccer we barely had
enough to put together a soccer team so
soccer and basketball they didn't have
enough for baseball didn't have enough
for like a track team anything like that
so uh realized pretty quick basketball
was not going to be my go-to for the
future so stuck with with soccer so
played soccer basically all my life up
until College time frame
how come you couldn't play basketball
uh genetics probably had a piece of that
work ethic probably had another piece of
that I just never really applied myself
to the skill of basketball I loved it I
like being out there and like playing
around with my buddies I was just never
gonna go anywhere basketball being a six
foot tall guy with limited athletic
abilities it was not going to be my
sport but soccer you were good I was
decent I was not great but again it
comes down more to my lack of actually
applying myself to any sport whatsoever
like if you contrast me to my sister my
younger sister who went to play uh D1
college at TCU for four years I would
argue exponentially more naturally
gifted I was very fast I was athletic uh
did not apply myself whatsoever like
didn't enjoy the experience of practice
I like playing in the games but you
contrast that with her she would be at
home if we were at home she was playing
soccer she was kicking the ball off the
side of the garage which drove my
parents crazy she she had net set up and
she was always practicing and surprise
surprise hard work paid off and she got
scholarships to go play at a D1 college
and I did not get the same opportunities
post high school to go play college
anywhere because you were a slacker I
was a very big slacker when it came to
to sports
all right so then you you get done with
this school you do you go to like a
Christian High School as well no so the
Christian School kind of tapped out
about the time I was going into high
school age I think ninth grade was my
last year at the Christian school and
then I think it just kind of ran out of
steam ran out of funding parents weren't
sending their kids there so we went to
the uh the public school for 10th 11th
and 12th grade graduated from there
played soccer there did everything what
position did you play in soccer I was a
defense usually right right back on
defense now what else are you into at
this time
um you're going to high school yeah are
you getting in trouble what are your
grades like my grades were decent but
again not really applying myself to it
but I was pretty naturally able to form
good study habits and I would pick
things up pretty quickly so A's and B's
yeah I don't think I had one C on my
record but again that wasn't from
opening books when I got home and
cracking it was more just getting by on
natural talent and then part of that too
was I had an ability to build good
relationships with my teachers and I
think they kind of watched out for me
every now and then
did you I didn't do homework no we
didn't I didn't bring and it's kind of
crazy you're gonna see this when your
kids get a little older yeah like when
they get to high school like my kids
well I should say this my daughters did
a lot of homework my son somehow I don't
know why he was somehow did not happen
because he had a good smile the skinny
charm yeah you would make good
relationships with the teachers and that
would probably help them out a little
bit I did not have homework that often
uh and if I did it was always last
minute stuff it was I pride myself on my
ability to procrastinate and then cram
and get the job done when I was in high
school for the most part speaking of
jobs were you working I was working all
kinds of different stuff in high school
so uh when you're in Texas you can get a
what they call it maybe it's a learner's
permit when you're a worker's permit
When You're 15 to get your license if
you have a job so I was like I can get a
car and have some Freedom a year earlier
if I have a legit job so I had a bunch
of different jobs that I was working I
was a ranch hand for a little bit for
some of our neighbor which if you've
ever tried Ranch handing in Texas in the
summertime highly recommend it it's a
very enjoyable experience very character
building very character building uh what
are you doing as a ranch handle 15 years
old what do you have to do so a lot of
it was mending fences taking care of the
property uh this older couple they were
some characters for sure they were like
some some Texas characters for sure and
we'd show up me and uh another buddy who
lived out in the middle of nowhere we'd
show up at like seven o'clock in the
morning and they would just basically
have a punch list of stuff for us to do
and the lady's name who was the the wife
and they were probably in their
I'd say late 50s but they were Haggard
they were they were looking a little bit
older she'd come to the door every
single morning in a night shift with a
Coors Light in her right hand and a
cigarette in her left hand at seven
o'clock and she would give us the punch
list of uh of stuff to do and a lot of
it was
mend and fences cleaning out the barn at
the time they had these metal fences and
we had to go by and like scrape all of
the rust off of the metal fences and
then just repaint them all
one day there wasn't a whole lot to do
out on the ranch so she wanted us to to
do some work around the property she
wanted us to go into her like kind of
perimeter Garden around the house pull
up a bunch of weeds and do some
landscaping for us and she gave us a
tour to make sure that she knew we knew
what she wanted us to pull out like what
was it weed and what was in a weed and
we get to this one particular bush
and it looks a whole lot like a
marijuana plant and she sees myself and
my other high school age buddy just kind
of staring at this marijuana plant and
she's like oh that's uh that's called
the Texas cannabis I know it looks like
marijuana but it's definitely not
marijuana it's 100
marijuana that she was growing out there
for her little personal stash her her
husband's little personal stash but yeah
just whatever she needed basically done
that morning and she again lived out in
the middle of nowhere so it wasn't like
anyone was flying a helicopter over
trying to find her little one little
Bush she had going on but
yeah she was out there giving us stuff
to do uh did that for part of a summer
and then realized there's probably
easier jobs out there than Ranch handing
so I was a waiter in our town at a
restaurant called The Cotton Patch for a
couple of years and that was a uh almost
a pass down from my older sister who
worked there for a while so I was like
all right I can go there I can get some
tips I can make some good money so I
worked there for probably two two and a
half years and then right across the
street from the Cotton Patch there was a
record store called Music Man and it was
you know maybe twice the size of this
studio right here it was not a very big
store so I went over there and you know
interviewed for a job and the guy that
managed the place was a character a guy
named Rick he was Hispanic but he was
also I guess traditional Jew but he was
Hispanic so he didn't have like it
wasn't his background he converted to
Judaism he walked everywhere he had a
big cane he would wear like the yarmaka
everywhere kind of like the dude from
Kung Fu just kind of roaming about the
town of Corsicana but he was cool he was
super laid back he liked music and uh
you know he offered me a job and I
worked there probably all the way up
until my senior year and I ended up
managing that place uh interestingly
enough he pulled me aside one day and I
think I was probably 18 years old pull
me aside took me outside and told me he
had a alcohol problem which was like not
a shock to me whatsoever he came in like
reeking a vodka most of the days that we
were there and he asked me if I would
drive him up to Dallas and check him
into this rehab facility that he had
been scoping out so
Rick was cool dude was happy to help him
out so I drove him up there dropped him
off and uh he did not own the music man
he was the manager of the music man and
there was a guy up in Dallas Texas which
was about an hour north of us like big
city and he was the guy that owned the
music man and I don't even think I knew
his name at the time but in my mind I'm
thinking like this Mogul that lives in
Dallas you know owns all these
businesses and the music man is one of
his so I find his contact information
and some records at the store and I just
call him up to let him know what's going
on because Rick is the only reason this
business stays open he's there from like
eight o'clock in the morning until uh
eight at night when they shut down so
without Rick there is no music man
because I'm still in high school the
other employee is a buddy of mine from
high school
so it was a summer time so I call this
guy up and in my mind I'm like I'm gonna
make a play to freaking run the music
man like I'm taking over the music man
basically go big time going big time so
I call this guy up and I'm like hey
here's the deal I just take took Rick up
to this uh facility up in Dallas checked
him into rehab he's out of the picture
and there's a pause on the other end and
this guy goes well I guess that means
you know we gotta we gotta shut it shut
stuff down
and I said hey maybe but I've been
working here now for two and a half
years I know how this entire business
functions you know I can manage it for
you if you want uh if you want that to
be the case because it was summertime so
I had basically three months where I
could manage this place and give him
time to find
someone else to step in when I went off
to uh college and there's like a long
pause on the other end and he's like so
you you're confident you could run it
I'm like absolutely it's not a big I
mean it's there's like 300 records in
the store maybe like it's not a complex
operation I was like I can I got this so
I talk him into it and now I'm like all
right I'm poised to make my move because
at the time I was making 525 an hour as
an employee there minimum wage in Texas
so he
I convince him he says all right let's
let's go it's yours for the summer and
then you know I'll try to find someone
else to come in and run it when you go
off to college and I said hey I think
because I'm taking on all this extra
responsibility I've got to run inventory
I've got to run the books I've got to do
all the bank drop-offs all this stuff is
on me now
um I think I need a raise
there's a pause on the other end and he
says
you're right you're right you do deserve
a raise so now I'm like I just this is
like the art of the deal right here like
I just took this place over this place
is now mine I'm gonna be making some
good money I can buy a new car what I
forgot was to actually talk about what
that raise would look like I didn't
throw a number out he purposely did not
throw a number out as well so I get my
next paycheck and I got a whopping 25
cent Bob
in the old paycheck so I went from 525
to 550 for managing that place over the
summer dude who shops at music man with
a city of like 20 or a town of 20 000
people characters how many records are
you selling on an average day maybe like
four oh this is CDs by now right these
are CDs tapes uh a lot of tape still
would come through it's Corsicana like
there's you know there's a lot of
vehicle still with with tape players in
them so we sold some tapes we sold some
CDs uh but it was not we were not moving
a whole lot what was the biggest
best-selling record underground rap was
the best selling record for us so we
were in between Dallas and Houston and
Houston had a big rap scene so
underground Kings a whole bunch of
different bands there are groups I guess
that unless you grew up in the Texas
area you'd have no idea probably who
these people were but they were a big
deal for us so someone came in odds are
they were walking out with some type of
screwston was the uh the kind of the
genre that it fell on our spruced and
wrap so that was our biggest seller yeah
every now and then you know a band would
you know
some metal band would release something
new corn would come out with a new album
and you'd sell 10 15 of those but it was
almost always kind of the Houston
underground rap game
okay and what were you into for music
metal so were you into music oh I loved
it yeah so music was a Thing music was a
thing yeah I dabbled in Guitar when I
was younger again didn't really apply
myself that much to it but I enjoyed
picking it up and playing around with it
um my dad was kind of old school uh
classic rock type guy you know Belinda
The Beatles some Zeppelins some Pink
Floyd Beach Boys throwing in randomly so
we grew up kind of on a blend of that
and then my mom loved uh
like 1980s Christian music so dang
Carmen freaking I'm trying to think
yeah Carmen's a dude he has some wild
videos back in the day where he was like
gunslinging against Satan uh so it was a
blend of either we hopped in the car if
it was it was my mom's Suburban it was
going to be uh Amy Grant or Carmen or
something like that and if we hopped up
with my dad it was probably going to be
the classic rock station you know some
Zeppelin stuff like that so isn't it
crazy that like you can still get in the
car today and just listen to Zeppelin
yeah like I mean like radio stations are
playing it yeah as they probably will
for the remainder of Eternity which is
not something that you could say about a
lot of the music that's getting made
right now for sure yeah yeah I had a
weird uh realization so
when I was in I guess it was probably
like eighth grade
and I don't know what it's like for you
but for me every single like school
dance that we went to yeah which started
in seventh grade eighth grade and then
we went to high school it had 9th 10th
11th 12th grade we had every dance I
ever went to
Stairway to Heaven was the last song of
the night right every single dance I've
ever been to In My Life as a as a human
because I've you only you know you don't
go to dance graduate high school
every single one who's a Stairway to
Heaven
and this so this is like 1984 1985
through 89.
so Led Zeppelin was around yeah in 1980
right so this is like four or five years
old
and I thought to myself it seemed like
when I was a kid it seemed like those
albums were like ancient it was like we
called it classic rock yeah it was
called classic rock even though
you know this what what did steroid
haven't come out 1972 something like
this maybe 1973. so it was only 10 years
old it was only 10 years old
so now like when my son was growing up
he was listening to Metallica
but Metallica was 1982. yeah so and my
son's growing up in 2020.
so like it's 40 years old 40 years old
of course Metallica still touring yeah
God bless him but it's just weird how
that music
for me when I was whatever 12 years old
13 years old it seemed like that music
was classic and old but it was only 10
years old yeah
so it's a totally different world yeah
there's uh and Zeppelin's always going
to be there Metallica it's always going
to be there at least their old stuff is
always going to be there yeah oh we got
a little man yeah there's a little shot
there's a
their course of Canada there was not a
lot of Led Zeppelin getting played at
the school dances it was a whole lot of
Garth Brooks George Strait that type of
stuff so okay
um I found metal in high school because
some of my buddies uh were listening to
it and that was all I listened to from
there on out until probably
a platoon or two into the SEAL Teams
when I opened up my horizons a little
bit but it was all old school Metallica
I say old school it wasn't you know it
wasn't that old for me either when I was
going through uh High School Megadeth
stuff like that and my kids listen to
the same thing my kids listen to that
stuff now I'll catch my oldest son Ronin
up in the garage every now and then in
our barn our hangout Barn if you will
our family Barn we have our gym and
stuff in there and he'll break one of my
guitars out and he's just shredding uh
Metallica and stuff and to my wife
Chagrin that's what they want to listen
to is Metallica maybe death I try to
convince her to look if you is the music
loud yes it's loud is it fast yes it's
fast if you listen to the lyrics there's
nothing wrong good messages what's those
lyrics it's all kids dealing with stuff
it's all
stuff about war it's all people just
working through problems
spinning it and do the best possible yes
yeah yeah I got AC DC Back in Black in
1980 so I'm nine years old and I was
like oh but then I got Black Sabbath
yeah and then I was like oh yeah okay
now I understand the world yeah that's
the uh that's my oldest son's go-to on
the guitar right now is Iron Man and Old
Black Sabbath he's figuring it out can't
go wrong now when you're when you're
that age
and you got stuff I mean probably every
teenage boys going through some stuff
but for for me about the time when I
found all that stuff my parents had
split up they split up a while before
but like the divorce was official right
then so I was
angry frustrated all those things that
you know a young kid with a very
self-centric world view is probably uh
going through and like that music just
spoke to me for the first time I was
listening to stuff and I was like it's
like it's okay to be frustrated about
stuff it's okay to be angry about
different stuff and you're listening to
these guys just pour all of their
personal experiences into and you're
like hey I can relate
it has to be also testosterone right for
sure like you're 15 years old 16 years
old you got testosterone coming out your
freaking eyeballs and like when there's
a such a thing as Roid Rage yeah right
for a reason like people go on steroids
and they get like Angry so when you're
15 of course you're going to be freaking
shit's gonna piss you off for sure man
so so that's luckily I mean if you look
at Metallica like how old was Metallica
they were like that age when when their
first albums came out 18 19 years old
when their first albums come out insane
and they're dealing with all of all of
those things all the same things and
that's why it will always be around
because you'll always have young men
going through those exact same things
and not only is the music
insanely well orchestrated and put
together but the lyrics young men at
least Young American men are always
going to hear that and they're always
going to be able to resonate with them
yeah it just it just lands I remember
the first time I heard Black Sabbath I
was like oh this is what I thought this
is what I was thinking yeah you know
what I mean like especially you compare
it to some of the other junk that was
out there in the world oh yeah like
there's just some junk music out there
popular music I I don't know I was stuck
on some radio station it was just
playing these ballads like these sort of
metal rock ballads they're disgusting
they're literally disgusting yeah
all right so you're now 15 16 your
parents are split up you're freaking
working in this record store for five
twenty five twenty five an hour but
didn't you get a raise to 55.50 now
looking up things are looking up you
have a car did you buy a car I did
what'd you buy so uh I can't believe I
ever sold this car but my well my first
car was the the parents Suburban this
best freaking 1989 Guacamole green
Suburban hell yeah that uh my dad bought
off a lot and he got a great deal on it
because it was legitimately Guacamole
green I think it was like the forest
service tree vehicle cover a color and
to make it look better he put a big gray
stripe right down the middle of it like
somehow that was gonna improve it so I
drove that around as I was saving my
cash up and then uh we went to a swap
meet up at the ballpark in Arlington in
Dallas and this was back in the day
before muscle cars were
astronomically expensive right and I
drove off the lot in a 1970 Chevelle
Super Sport for a six grand oh my God
midnight blue white racing stripes so
now you're talking about the
testosterone Fuel Metallica and now I've
got you know a 454 sitting there and it
was uh I was is a kid always in the car
it's always into muscle cars and I was
just fortunate enough to live in a place
in a time where a young man who was
willing to do a little bit of work could
afford something like that it got
probably eight miles to the gallon but
fuel in Texas was like 97 cents back
then so uh that's what I had until
college and then I will forever kick
myself but I sold it when I went to
college because you always tinkering
with old with old cars there's always
something that you got to fix on them
and I was thinking I need a little bit
more reliable transportation and I sold
it and then I sold it for more than I
paid for it yeah but what'd you get to
replace it I got a uh what the hell did
I get
I think I had bought an old uh Land
Rover like a 1995 I guess it wasn't that
old I was old it's only 2001 so it's
probably like a six-year-old Land Rover
yeah which
talking about things that need to be
fixed all the time yeah I think need to
be fixed all the time so it wasn't
necessarily the best the best swap but
you know I was 16 years old driving that
sucker around no no air condition didn't
care loud exhaust just just crushing
life at that point in time basically so
when did you find out about the teams oh
so I was probably either 14 or 15 years
old and I was an Avid Reader growing up
I read all the time always had books in
my hand uh you name it I was reading it
and we spent a ton of time at the
library and part of that was probably my
mom was a teacher so
um we were always at the library my mom
was a teacher I didn't reach you didn't
read anything
yeah my dad was a teacher too I still
didn't really do that I loved it I would
get lost in all these different books
and it could be I lived out in the
middle of nowhere too and there just
wasn't a whole lot of stuff to do
besides play in the woods and read so I
was always reading these Adventure
novels and whatnot and pretending to be
those I'd read a book and then I'd go
out in the woods and just basically
pretend to be one of those those
characters when I was young but we spent
a bunch of time in the Corsicana public
library and I was uh in the military
history section and this was before you
know pre-911 this was like 1995
four or five maybe something like that
maybe 1996 there was not a lot of
information out there about the SEAL
Teams and I stumbled across this book
called hunters and Shooters and it was
this oral history of seals in Vietnam
and I read it and I was hooked like
instantaneously knew that's what I
wanted to do with the rest of my life I
was like I can get paid to do this I can
actually go and make a living out of
jumping out of airplanes and running
around in the jungle and diving and
doing all these things that you know
probably every young man dreams about
when they're when they're little so it
was a a huge turning point in my life
because up until then I was not very
disciplined about a whole lot of things
and it was very evident that if that's
something that I wanted to do it was
going to take every single thing that I
had I had a Channel all my energy into
that so everything from there on out
every decision I made basically became
the decision was is this going to help
me get into the SEAL Teams and if the
answer was no then I didn't do it so got
serious about working out got serious
about eating I think my parents thought
I was insane and full of it like my
parents grew up watching a very
undisciplined uh young man who like you
know I I wasn't horrible like I was a
good kid but I wasn't the hardest worker
growing up we lived on a farm we had
horses we had emus we had all kinds of
random crap on the farm I was always
complaining about work and then just
whatever it was about reading that book
it was just like a switch that went off
and like I was very focused and all of a
sudden I'm working out on my own I'm
studying because I want to get good
grades so that I can get into the
community because I I don't know if that
mattered or not but I'm like it's got to
help you know if I've got straight A's
it looks good so it was a big turning
point for me
it's a weird realization when you are
running around in the Woods playing army
and then you realize you can actually do
that yeah yeah
literally my first thought was I've been
doing this my entire life and now this
is something that I can get paid to do
uh go on these crazy and this is stuff
event Vietnam I mean this is insane
stuff I was reading and it just
resonated and I was like I want to do
this I have to be a part of this
community I at least have to see if I
can if I can make it oh yeah I was going
to Nam yeah
that was that was my plan I was like
going to nam I figured it was still Ops
come on man there's am I the pows and
Mia's like I will be rescuing them I
just got to make it through buds that
was kind of what I was thinking what's
going on I've already got the plan built
down 1990. let's roll uh so you graduate
high school then now you're now you're
focused on like I'm gonna be a frog man
I'm gonna be a seal and where you go to
college I went to Texas a m i how come
you just didn't enlist so it went back
and forth on whether to enlist and not
and my parents played a big role in me
not enlisting and uh what they told me
was it was a shock to them that I wanted
to do this you know my uh not
necessarily a big military family my
mom's side had some service but like my
parents didn't serve anything like that
and I think they were again having a
hard time wrapping their mind around the
fact that like I was actually capable of
doing something like this so I oh so you
mean they doubted you I think so it was
literally nobody I think that thought I
was serious about it or thought that I
was going to make it through uh and I
can't blame them if you looked at you
know my life up until then it was kind
of the antithesis of what you needed to
do to actually make it through a program
like that so in their minds I think it
was more of a delay tactic like how do
we get him to realize he's not meant to
do this how do we get him to realize
that there's other things in life that
he can do let's let him ruminate on this
for a little bit so they were talking to
me about college and just said look if
you still want to you can enlist after
college too but we want you to get your
degree first that is a tactic for sure
by the way get your kid to go to college
they meet a girl they do this they get a
job offer and you keep them out of the
military yes I've seen some people
execute on that plan I'd be willing to
bet because I never actually asked him
but I'd be willing to bet that was their
tactic was hey get him into college he's
going to figure some other stuff out
even if he doesn't and he still wants to
do it now he's got a degree if he
doesn't make it or just doesn't like it
he's got something he can fall back on
uh so they were probably thinking get
him to college he'll have a good time
yeah uh he'll lose focus and he'll you
know find some other path find a girl
and settle down but unbeknownst to them
I was the lamest college student of all
time is it hard to get into Texas you
went to Texas Texas A M and is it hard
to get in there I don't I don't think
it's necessarily I mean it's not Harvard
let's be honest but uh you know you
still have to have good grades you still
have to
um you know contribute that type of
thing so I think they at the time it's a
state school but they're still decently
selective I think you had to be more or
less in the top 10 percent of your class
at the time to make it through so you
were I was obviously yeah I was around
you know probably like the 10th percent
yeah yeah I was just slid right in
underneath there but uh I chose to go
there because there was the core Cadets
is there and there's a group inside the
core of cadets that were just focused on
getting people prepared for selection
babe for buds for the the Seal training
Pipeline and to me like it's like this
is a great resource I can go down there
I can work out with these guys I can
better myself I'll prepare it'll help me
be more prepared basically so I went
down there I was not in the core of
cadets
um I just worked out with these guys and
I mean they were I thought I was in good
shape you know I was running I put in
like three miles uh I would do some
calisthenics and stuff and I thought I
was in good shape and then day one
running with these guys it was just like
a nuclear bomb went off it was the worst
experience in my life these guys were
all just freaks these guys were actually
in shape is what it was these were
actual uh Runners you know they were
putting in like 18 minute three mile
times which to me was like unattainable
at the time basically so it was a very
good thing for me to choose to go there
because it framed my perspective on my
own personal training so you know my day
in college consisted of I would be up at
4 24 25 at the latest I'd get a cup of
coffee and then I'd have to drive to
campus Because 4 45 we would be starting
at PT and then we would PT until about 6
30 then we'd hit the chow hall and then
my classes didn't start till eight so I
would go to our gym and I would get
another workout in because when you're
19 20 years old you can do stuff like
that it's not gonna break you down
basically so we PT for about an hour and
a half together I'd eat I'd go PT some
more and then we would go to class and
then after class I would go to my uh my
job which was I was working in the
school system as a uh after school kind
of counselor for a underprivileged
school that was nearby Texas A M so I'd
go do that until 5 30 6 o'clock at night
I'd come home eat dinner study for a
couple hours and then I'd be asleep by
probably 8 30 9 o'clock I was the lamest
college student of all time I can you
know maybe three parties I ever went to
because my roommates were going and I
just didn't enjoy them because in the
back of my mind I was just very
concerned about getting in trouble if I
get in trouble and I want to be an
officer and get picked up for that
program if I get you know arrested or in
a fight or something like that
everything that I've worked for is over
with so it was just wake up PT school
sleep did you start to get in really
good shape I got in very very good shape
very good shape uh
better than some of those guys at
certain things I was a little bit bigger
than most of them so when it came to
like calisthenics I was better at it
than them but when it came to running I
was always tail in so we would have a
three mile time run at the end of each
semester just to track our progress and
it was a three mile Loop but it wasn't
I'm sorry one mile Loop that you would
run three times but it wasn't a good
actual test of your three mile time
because half of the loop was uphill so
you'd you know run downhill basically in
the last half would be uphill and I ran
an 1820 and I was the slowest guy about
like 45 seconds damn we had guys that
were putting in 1645s they were just
Freaks and we were swimming all the time
and these guys were all trying to go to
buds all trying to go to buds all trying
to go to buds
what did you study in College speech
Communications for no other reason than
I thought it would be easy and get me
out of college quick I also thought if I
was going to be an officer I probably
needed the ability to actually
speak in front of people and I thought
in my back of my mind like this will
probably help me hone my public speaking
skills what I didn't realize is you
didn't speak at all it was just all
paper writing it's like the worst major
I possibly could have taken outside of
maybe a dedicated like engineering
course because every semester each
course that I was taking had like a 30
page paper that was attached to that
course it's called Speech communication
communication it's basically developed
for people that wanted to go and be like
PR reps and stuff which I didn't know
any of that like I'm picking this out of
a catalog of what I thought would be the
easiest major for me so that I could
just focus on
pting and being ready for the SEAL Teams
so you start at some point you got to
put your package in right yep to become
a seal did you go to the did you go to
the mini buds thing I did not so they
actually stopped that right about the
time when I should have been able to go
and
I'm not sad that that happened because
when I got there and then I started to
actually later on in my career when I
was running one of the phases of of
selection what I found out was mini buds
never really helped anybody but it
definitely could hurt people so if you
came to minibuzz and you did well the
message that I was told was
yeah it kind of helps not really but if
you came to mini Buds and you didn't do
well or you didn't perform like you're
done you're over with so uh I didn't
have the opportunity to go I didn't even
have the opportunity to talk to a board
or anything like that I just put
together a package I sent it in and it
got examined by some board somewhere
probably in Millington Tennessee or
maybe in Coronado I don't know where and
then they kind of decided your fate from
there so no even interviews you didn't
even interview no letter of
recommendation from anybody letter
recommendation so we had a couple of
guys that were a m alumni Team guys Team
guys yeah I can't even remember their
names anymore damn yeah
um but like there was a network
basically of a m guys that had graduated
that were willing to help out so
they just talked me on the phone for a
few minutes and then wrote me a pretty
nice Rec letter but that was really it
like I didn't spend time with those
people or anything and this is what 2000
and it's probably seven two thousand two
thousand five time frame was when I was
starting to put the package together so
at this time there's so many people
applying to be honest I mean there's
like probably let's just say I think the
number would probably be around a
thousand I would imagine probably around
a thousand people would be applying and
it would be like
30 yeah slots yep total is that probably
30 from the Naval Academy it'd probably
be a little bit more than 30 total but
for OCS officer candidate school which
was the program I would have to go
through because I didn't go the Naval
Academy I wasn't in the core of cadets
so uh I think the number was around like
15 people God selected that from the
whole country from the whole country and
you were one of them did you have to
write an essay I did not have to write
an essay I had to write just a bit
little bio about why I wanted to be what
did you say program just hey I wanted to
serve I wanted to lead I wanted to give
back
pretty much all the generic things that
they probably wanted to hear there was
nothing that you think made you stand
out I think my PT scores probably made
me say yeah how good were your PT scores
they were pretty good they were pretty
good how many pull-ups did you do I did
like 32 pull-ups I did 147 push-ups
that's freaking yeah
um I did
what was your run from mile and a half a
mile and a half run was not super
impressive but it was you know it was
competitive it was probably a uh ride it
around 8 59 I think my swim was good I
was a good no I actually I was a
horrible swimmer but I was good at side
stroke all I did was side stroke so my
swim time was phenomenal for not being
someone who grew up swimming so I think
my PT scores uh were your grades in
college are good my grades were good you
know again I wasn't taking engineering
classes then you have to take I think I
took like some kind of a test for OCS
I could get into OCS I don't think I
took a test I took the officer aptitude
test yes I did I took a test called the
officer aptitude testing okay crushed
that thing what was on it it was
mechanical stuff okay it was planes
coming at you and going away from you
and where where is this plane coming
towards you or going after you uh
mechanical like gears which way is this
thing going a bunch of math problems a
bunch of English stuff yeah and I like
crushed that thing that does sound
familiar that does sound actually very
familiar I'm actually I remember sitting
in the recruiter's office in College
Station doing that exam that I did well
on it so you get picked up by someone
that's it's hard to get picked up for
that program I was uh sure I was I mean
it's like the best day of my life when I
got that letter when I got picked up
yeah so you get picked up for that but
then you have to wait like in here or
something yeah why was that I had an
injury so I I tore my shoulder when I
was in early college Years and then I
had as a labrum terrorist so nothing
nothing too traumatic but I had to have
it repaired and they took forever to
clear that through a medical board and
you know I'm super frustrated at the
time because in my mind I'm like I have
delayed I didn't enlist I delayed to go
to college I've been training I'm ready
to roll I thought I was going to get
picked up and then like the day I
graduated freaking go in my mind that's
what was going to happen and I it was
about a year almost a year and a half
before they cleared me of all that stuff
and it was exceptionally frustrating for
me for one because they have all my PT
scores like it's clearly not a
debilitating injury whatsoever like I
crushed the PT portion of it so I'm I'm
you know clearly physically able to do
this job so it was probably a blend of
just how long it actually takes people
to clear those medical boards I doubt a
doctor sat there and looked at my
paperwork for a year and a half it
probably took him a year and a half to
get to my paperwork in the giant stack
of paperwork that he had to work through
so it was frustrating
I moved back to my hometown I taught
actually for a year in our school system
uh as my job and then just kind of
typical Navy you know wait wait wait
wait wait and then all of a sudden a
call comes that says hey you're leaving
in two weeks basically for for OCS so I
was very frustrated that I had to wait
that long but in the grand scheme of
things uh it was probably the best thing
that could have happened to me because
you look at the trajectory of what it
put me on as far as the deployments that
I got to go on the people I got to work
for uh and with I met my wife because of
this timeline all of those things played
out because of this so I wouldn't change
one thing about it
all right so you launched to OCS yeah
how do you like OCS it was freaking
miserable uh I was I I wanted to be the
best I possibly could be so I I drove to
OCS from Texas and it was up in Rhode
Island so that's like a 18 or 19 hour
drive and the whole Drive I was
reviewing all the materials they told us
to come prepared you know all of your
the sailors Creed all of those things
that you were going to have to recite
and I get there and at the time I've got
this big you know Ford F-250 King Ranch
diesel I've got cowboy boots on like I'm
going to check into this place and I'm
just getting the once over from all of
these uh Cadets that are there kind of
running the initial days so I get there
you know they're being super cool like
oh yeah man you know it's great blah
blah blah and then they take me into
this hallway and then that's when you
know The Jig Is up that's when that's
when you're theirs basically so these
guys come busting out these
upperclassmen like they're down and
screaming at me and stuff and to me I'm
just like this is a freaking joke dude
like this is crazy to me that this is
stressing people out but like there was
a couple of guys with me and a couple of
girls with me and they were freaked out
by this but you know previous life
experiences and whatnot like I've been
yelled at plenty of times so it wasn't
that big of a deal uh the process of OCS
not a huge fan of it but I wouldn't
change anything because I my drill
instructor a guy named jacovoni Gunnery
Sergeant jacovoni like the classic
Marine Jewel instructor it's the
freaking man and I learned so much from
that guy from a leadership perspective
but he also knew what I wanted to do and
he took a special interest in me because
I wanted to go and do this combat MOS
which is what all Marines care about
basically so he gave me a lot of
additional privileges that other people
going through did not get it's like what
I spent time in his office talk I was
the you know he made me the class
president basically so at first I was
really annoyed by that because I thought
that meant that I would not have time to
PT uh but he was really putting me in
that position so that he could have
extra access with me and give me the
things that I basically needed like
extra time so did I pay the man for
being the class president when the class
screwed up yeah all the time but it also
meant that we got to spend a lot of time
together so I'd go to his office and he
would just talk to me about stuff we sat
down we watched Band of Brothers
together and he was walking me through
like all these different Leadership
Lessons Learned From Band of Brothers he
was exceptionally hard on me like he was
not you know he held me to a very high
standard and if the class screwed up I
paid the man for it big time uh but by
the end of it you know I was when I was
the senior class on deck if you will I
was the regimental Commander so I was a
guy running basically all of OCS
um and you know after the day was over
me him and another couple of the Marine
Gunnies like we'd go out in town and
have a drink and get dinner and you know
you got like Silver Star winners that
are there that are these Gunnery
sergeants and they're just teaching me
just teaching me so from that
perspective I freaking loved it but from
the day-to-day perspective God I was
miserable you know you're you're using
all these they're teaching all these
skills that in the SEAL Teams you're
just never going to use like your
Mobility boards your navigation board
stuff like that yeah I'm not good at
math so that stuff to me
they kicked my butt I uh the mow boards
kicked my butt and then the the
the test that you have to go through to
get in like the physical test I'm not
flexible and there's this weird dynamic
at OCS where some of the Gunnery
sergeants really like each other and
they have like a crew and then other
Gunnery sergeants don't like this crew
and they look for the guys and gals that
this crew likes and they try to harass
them and like kick them out so I was not
flexible so we're doing this like toe
touching test and I couldn't freaking
touch my toes and I was about to get
booted out of the program because I
couldn't touch my toes and yeah it came
over and basically saved me from that
experience so put his knee in your back
literally got me down there so Mobility
boards and physical Mobility were my two
biggest weaknesses in in OCS but uh
overall the experience of getting to
learn from him was awesome and you know
I met two of my best friends at OCS
there was two other guys that were three
other guys that were going to go through
the same program so we were all either
in the same class or within one class of
each other so we all moved out to
Coronado together and rented a place
together as to go through buds so
um from that perspective it was great
from a day-to-day how was OCS
perspective it was just 13 weeks of
being miserable not eating enough food
getting out of shape compared to the
shape that I went into it folding
underwear folding under ironing
underwear all of the things that are
going to make you very I guess a good
sailor okay all right so you graduate
and now you're out you you go the world
a few of your buddies to go out to buds
roll through my buddies go out to buds
one of them uh my buddy Sam is a
Coronado kid water polo player built
like a refrigerator uh just total stud
but he grew up in Coronado so you know
he knew all the lay of the land so he
basically picked a good place for us to
live down there in in the case yeah yeah
and had we actually rented from an older
team guy as a captain in the Navy who
his family was friends with so we live
there okay I think I know who you're
talking about yeah we lived there and
and went through training and it was
just the best time it possibly could be
and one of my buddies who was going
through training James his wife is a
two-time Olympian so she was like our
den mother like she was there living
with us Olympian in what 800 meter
Runner okay total total animal just so
fast and I went on a couple runs with
her and it was just like the most
embarrassing thing of all time because
she'd be having a conversation with me
and I can't even breathe like I can't
I'm like sucking wind and she's just
conversational Pace basically but she
was there in the house with us uh so
she'd go up to like the training center
during the days and prep for the
freaking Olympics and then we'd all go
to Buds and just get our teeth kicked in
basically how was your how was your
intro to buds uh it was awesome so I was
nervous at first because I've put so
much time and energy
into preparing for this and I was
nervous about how I was going to stack
up against everybody else that was there
because you know everyone in my mind did
the exact same things to prepare
everyone you know logged thousands of
hours of running and swimming yeah
because you basically spent four years
at Texas A M preparing to go to butts
every single morning doing that every
single morning preparing for buds so
that's good preparation it was
outstanding and the whole time too we're
also doing different stuff for like
water comfortabilities things that you
probably actually shouldn't do without
supervision but we were doing other
things like drown proofing and stuff
that got you more comfortable in the
waters it was outstanding outstanding
prep but in my mind I was very nervous
about how I was going to stack up with
everybody else and uh I was just fine
you know I was
up there at the top with a lot of things
I was never going to be the fastest
runner I never fell out of a run never
but I was never going to be the top of
the pack like will you do a Four Mile
time run and I would be by the time we
would run back through the rock passage
I would just be getting past left and
right by people yeah just gas that's
just falling apart I would start this is
another crazy thing about the guys at a
m is they didn't their running style was
how I learned to run was they would just
take off top speed right from the
version they would just straight up just
go uh
and that would be the pace they would
keep the entire time so I would get a
big lead taking off and I don't think I
got gassed coming back it was just that
nobody else was actually trying that
hard until the halfway mark and then the
guys that were really freak Runners
would just start to put on you know the
five minute pace and they would just fly
past yeah yeah was when you were going
through buds are you looking was there
studs that you were you know everyone
talks about the stud that queer right oh
yeah yeah because you have some of those
for sure there was uh kind of the usual
characters and if you went through budge
you know what I mean by the usual
characters of the guys that you think
are just gonna crush it one because they
look like it and two because they tell
you they're just gonna crush it and then
eventually those guys just go away but
you had you know D1 athletes that came
through there and washed out you had
these guys that were second and third
offenders trying to come through the
program that knew everything there was
to know about buds uh and they would
wash out so there was definitely you
know people that you would line them up
on day one and say hey come and pick
who's going to make it
and probably most people would pick the
guys that washed out and would be my
guess that's pretty wild isn't it yeah
it is it's very wild now there also was
some legit athletes that did just fine
yeah yeah some wrestlers for whatever
reason crush it and I think the reason
is they're just used to being miserable
yeah all the time like if you're a
wrestler your life is just miserable
your practice are miserable you're
starving yourself all the time you know
you're pushing yourself super hard and
buds is just a case study of can you be
miserable for seven months and some of
those athletes I think what it was is
they're very used to
doing everything right getting
everything right and then when they fail
it messes with them they're not used to
it and they get on this kind of downward
spiral so a lot of guys washed out
before hell week kicked off and then
during hell week a lot of those other
big strapping young Lads were were not
there and then some of the little guys
who were just tough as Nails just
tenacious just they're not gonna
freaking quit we're there what was how
like how we collect for you any big deal
how do you say this without seeming like
you know kind of a
egomaniac but it really
the thought of hell week was much worse
to me than hell week once we started and
we got going it was tough it was the
hardest thing I've ever done in my life
but I think an advantage I had was I was
an officer so I'm not necessarily
worried about my own individual
performance I'm worried about my boat's
performance and if if if I pass a run
but my team doesn't pass a run I still
get freaking beat for it so because I
was more focused on the guys and I
wasn't as focused on my own personal
misery I think it made it a little bit
more bearable uh for me the thing that I
hated the most about buds was the cold
and hell week is just you're just cold
the entire time so that's right you're a
Texas boy we didn't cold water that
doesn't exist I would go to our lakes in
Texas the water temp would be like 91
degrees
so Ross used to also use the water of
Maine no I was surfing in Maine in the
wintertime I got out to California I was
like yo this is easy
it was just no Factor no it was if you
said you can do a log PT or you can sit
in the ocean for surf torture I would do
the log PT every single time most people
would not say that most people had like
no opinion of things I was I was sort of
just an automaton of like hey this is
what we're doing I kind of was like yo
let's go do it yeah I don't know I was
kind of having a good time and for me
hell week was the easiest part because
it couldn't fail yeah
there's no standard it's just keep going
it's the standard just keep going which
I'm good at yeah like I'm real good at
that but like oh the the Four Mile time
run was it hard for me those time swims
they were hard for me the obstacle
course was hard for me everything else
was like I'm fighting the clock
and but in hell week I was like oh you
oh I can't fail this boat's on head
carried down to freaking IBM back cool I
can keep going let's do this let's go
yeah yeah the uh the obstacle course and
all that stuff I was good at all of
those things but the obstacle course I
ended up always just getting beat for
even I was like the second best in my
class at the obstacle course the the guy
that was the best his name's Mike he was
a total stud he was a guy that made Buzz
look easy basically total stunt
um but because we were number one and
number two for that particular Evolution
what do the instructors always want to
do face off between uh Sean and Mike
Mike destroyed me every single time like
it unless he lawn darted off of the
slide for life and broke something like
there was no chance I had in beating
Mike so we'd finish and I would get beat
because I lost to Mike basically that
obstacle course was freaking awesome
it's amazing it is freaking awesome yeah
it is like a giant adult playground yeah
yeah his time going through there I
think the best I ever did was like 6 20
and he was consistently putting up like
five thirties dude a guy in my class was
getting like eight minute eight minute
eight minute whatever if you're all
through buds
we're doing like our last obstacle
course and he breaks out like a five
and the instructors are like what the
is it about the truck going crazy
do it again they go do it again
he's like okay he does again he gets
like a 440 or something like this he was
just sandbagging yeah for six months of
buds just sandbag well I don't know that
I was sandbagging but I had never put up
a 6 30 before and then uh one of the
instructors said Hey to the whole class
if you don't get underneath eight
minutes you're getting wet and Sandy
before the next Evolution like we don't
care that it's a passing grade like
you're you're getting me basically so I
always was around that eight minute Mark
so I was like well I really gotta
freaking turn it on and that's when I
ran you know a 6 45 or something and
then from there on out I was like oh I
can I can go faster basically but Mike
was always just smoking me and I pulled
him aside one day and I asked him I was
like yo man how are you like what's your
secret man like what are you doing
differently
and he wasn't trying to be a prick about
or anything but he just said hey I don't
actually even try until I get to the
slide for life and then I really just
conserve energy and then put it on and
I'm like bro what I'm a hundred percent
from the uneven bars you know the
parallel bars like that's I if I wasn't
100 from there I'd be back at like eight
minutes but his secret was he was in
such good shape he would not sandbag but
he would just jog the first piece and
then save himself for the the part where
most guys gas out and then he would just
pull it on I remember having to run it
wet and Sandy and then all all of our
classes running are wet and Sandy I was
thinking about that's one of the times I
was thinking to myself that this is not
safe
everything's just saying he had slippery
and I was like this doesn't seem safe
but I guess that's what we're doing so
let's go there was an evolution in hell
week we had to carry our boat yeah about
not safe let's get that boat up to the
uh
real quick a slide for life where in the
Obstacle of course where is that way
yeah halfway and it's a tower that you
have to climb it's three levels and by
the time you get there like you're
you're tired so this is where you really
more specifically your forearms are
tired your forearms are kind of smoked
because it's all hanging onto stuff it's
all ropes and climbing yeah and so your
your forearms are kind of smoke when you
get there so Jeremy told me and I I get
little bits and pieces of them oh course
experience
uh Jeremy told me the the so cake nuts
was going through and he kept jamming
himself up failing or whatever and he
was like yeah because his technique he
kept like bending his arms like trying
to like
[Music]
yeah he said Brad just keep your arms
straight and you won't burn out your
arms because you keep feeling on that
part it's like some rope I don't know so
when you come down you climb up three
stories and then it's just a long rope
that you slide down you know starting it
it goes from three stories to zero
stories okay and so you're kind of
hanging up so in the beginning you hang
upside down and go wait and that's the
slide for Life yeah you're sliding down
a rope but the Rope is kind of loose so
it's kind of like difficult to go down
yeah and your forearms can definitely
get smoked and people used to fall off
of it 30 feet 25 feet 20 feet I mean
following 20 feet sucks wait what do you
hit the sandwich and now they have they
put a net under it for a while and now
they have like sand berm underneath it
so you're not falling it used to be more
legit I think it's a motivator is really
what it's like when the gym when all the
gyms transition to the like soft kind of
box jumps instead of the oldest yeah
yeah like yeah look if people were
starting to try things that they
shouldn't have tried right like look you
don't have a 36 inch box jump with a
metal box like you're not trying that
yeah because there's repercussions there
if you fail so it's a little extra
motivator but uh that of course they had
Olympians when I was running the third
phase of training we had Olympians come
through because the Olympic Training
Center is in San Diego and they couldn't
make it it was all the grip string
they're so specialized that you just
have to be uh
you can't be an Olympic swimmer and
expect to go through that obstacle
course and crush it yeah they're too but
a gymnast would fly through I had a
gymnast I had a gymnast Olympic
alternate in my class oh my and he would
fly through it he unfortunately for him
wasn't good in the water and failed some
water Evolution and didn't make it but
all Olympic alternate and gymnastics
it's insane like going through the O
course was a joke they'd even use his
legs
there's like literally nothing for him
yeah uh any any other did you have any
challenges in buds
um besides the cold cold was the big one
uh drown proofing I was I was doing very
well you know past all the evolutions
and whatnot until drown proofing and I
was very confident about drown proofing
until I actually did drown proofing and
then it was just like absolute chaos
underwater it was the first time in my
buds experience where I was like this is
this is sketchy like this might be like
you might not make it I was thinking
like yo that was a vastly different
experience than what I was expecting
went through you know practice all the
procedures I was very comfortable in the
water and then it was uh like eye-opener
so next day show up and I managed to get
it done the second day but as most
nervous I've ever been was I was very
concerned about failing again the second
day but what about pool comp
um
sorry did I say drum proofing you said
drum proof yeah no drown proofing
um we practice it so much that it wasn't
really that big of a thing pull cop was
the one where it was like yo man this is
a different experience a very different
experience than in my mind what we had
built it up to be I was talking to a kid
trying to tell him that it was like hey
you need to prep for pool complex it's
really hard and he was kind of like you
know I'm good in the water like this is
no factor and then he didn't make it the
first time didn't make it the second
time third time and I talked to him when
he was done and he was like uh I go I
tried to tell you that was hard yeah and
he said nothing you could have told me
would have would have explained what it
was like there's like there's not much
of buds that I don't remember pretty
vividly I don't remember anything about
the first pool accomplishment other than
just other than it just being like a
you're a freaking tornado just Mayhem
absolute Mayhem uh Andy Stumpf was the
instructor
yeah you know you know Andy passed I
want to I think he said it's either
three or in the three years he was an
instructor he passed four people well I
was not one of those he's like and they
earned it yeah well I was underwater for
probably six minutes and I get to the
top and I'm just I don't even know where
I am at that point and he's like you
know you failed and I said okay well I
wanted to get some pointers and I said
okay well you know what's you know could
you you know specifically I could do
better he goes it was so short that I
don't even remember what went wrong and
I'm like okay thanks I swear I wish Andy
could have been just if they just could
have had a camera and a microphone on
Andy for the three years that he was a a
second phase instructor it would be the
best TV show of all time especially from
a comedic perspective yeah yeah yeah it
was one of those things where if you
were in his line you were trying to find
a way to get out of his life he was
talking to me about it and he's like
yeah he goes yeah he says you he goes
you learn a lot
she was telling you about like the
different hand positions that people
would have he's like you know the murals
I forget what it was but it was
something like oh when they started to
curl you'd be like oh he's about to bolt
like he's done and he could know how
much pressure to put on him or take off
of him and yeah so Andy Stumpf get some
yeah that was uh the worst five minutes
of my life up until that point in time
for sure so first base second phase they
liked our class we had a lot of
personality you know guys were hard
workers guys that were funny which buds
instructors always like classes that can
just kind of embrace it and then we got
to third phase and it was just they did
not like our class so third for whatever
reason third phase for us where we're
you're really excited about third phase
because you're like now I get to shoot I
get to blow stuff up I get to do all of
these cool things I get to learn land
Warfare third phase for us was just like
first phase beat down 2.0 just beat down
and now you're on an island where there
are no eyeballs watching you so uh we
spent more time getting beat than we did
actually shooting like we would go to
the range we'd probably get five minutes
of shooting in someone would screw
something up and then we'd be down on
the surf zone do you think you guys got
cocky because they like the instructors
like you in first and second phase and
you guys were kind of like hey we got
this and everyone loves us it could be a
part of it the personalities that were
in third phase at the time I think were
I've had a lot to say with that and
there was one Chief specifically who
ended up being being out there almost
the entire time not supposed to be but
just I think one time he had to cover
for another cell so we stayed out there
but and then it just became the snowball
thing like once the so for those that
don't know there's different cells in
third phase so they rotate out so the
Marksmanship cell will come out for the
first two weeks and run the class for
two weeks on this island called San
Clemente Island then they leave and the
demo cell comes out well the
Marksmanship cell is giving a turnover
to the demo cell of how the class is
doing and if the the turnover is these
guys suck
then the snowball starts happening so it
was in some ways worse than first phase
because no one was around to Reign
anything in and you're almost over the
mentality as a third phase student like
their beatings are always still going to
be there in buds but check you we're
supposed to be learning things now it
was not necessarily the case for our
third phase class
we just learned how to be hard again
yeah there you go
um
so you graduate graduate from buds which
is not really a graduation they just
give you a piece of paper now literally
a piece of paper shake your hand on the
grinder and send you along and then it's
off to sqt sqt for officers at this
point in time we got the what they call
the officer role so that we could go to
the junior officer training course which
I think we were
maybe the second or third class to
actually go through that because life
stood that thing up didn't it no he
didn't stand it up he took it over but
yeah this was now what this is 2009 2008
2008 okay yeah so life had been in there
for a while okay because
um but he didn't stand it up actually
who stood it up was Admiral Richards oh
okay so this is like in way early okay
this is like 2 000. uh but it wasn't
what Leif did was take it and turn it
from my hey this is how you write evals
this is how you write Navy messages
because you gotta remember well this is
probably what it was like for you too
like you didn't have any experience in
the Navy you didn't know how to write a
Navy message you know how to write an
evaluation you didn't do a bunch of Navy
stuff so they needed to give some of
that Navy stuff to guys and that's sort
of what it started off with and then
they started like bringing in some guys
that have been in combat and then Leif
actually was like hey we need to teach
guys some leadership while they're going
through this junior officer training
course so he did a great job of sort of
pivoting that and setting up the ftxs
and all that really good yeah so he was
there for I think the first two weeks
and then turned over with uh Mike
cirelli yeah took over so we went
through that it was awesome learned a
whole bunch of things what was not
awesome was we had some time to kill in
between when buds ended and when Johnson
started and I think it was because there
was a Christmas film between that
transition we did not have the class
before us only had I think three or four
officers in it that made it through so
they wanted to combine our two classes
so they needed to find something to fill
a gap between our class ending and then
when the Johnson was supposed to start
on the calendar and at the time there
was a Green Beret major
who was kind of augmenting the Johnson
cell with Mike cirelli and he convinced
the powers that be that it would be a
really good idea to send us to the Q
course during that time frame so we
shipped out to Camp McCall in February
and went through three weeks of the Q
course out there which was which how
much of the Q course is that so it's
right post selection it's now when
they're doing the small unit tactics
okay version of it right so in some ways
awesome because you're getting taught
but
he kind of saw this major kind of sold
the chain of command on the fact that it
was this portion of the Q course was
more of like a gentleman's course you're
going to be learning it's their
selection it's literally their selection
so we're out there digging foxholes at
night Camp McCall in February it's you
know 20 degrees outside you don't get to
wear any cool cool guy warm gear you're
in like your cotton freaking bdus out
there yeah it was a unique experience so
we did that for three weeks was supposed
to be the time frame I actually jacked
my knee up uh on a rock one night and
they had to send me back to get treated
in San Diego so I was only out there I
think for a week and a half of that but
during that time frame we learned about
ambushes we learned about layups we
learned some good stuff it was a crappy
experience for sure from uh from a
standpoint of a guy who just graduated
Buds and you're like cool that's now
behind me and now it's time to start
learning how to actually be an operator
and then get thrown right back into
selection
and not only selection but Green Beret
selection where all the instructors are
like let's see what these yeah I'll see
what these Navy guys can offer us type
thing
um
it's 100 let's see what they're all
about but the the flip side of that was
we did learn we did learn if you wanted
to if you took the time and actually
wanted to learn what they were telling
us then it was very valuable very
valuable all right so now you get done
with sqt and you roll into team seven
team seven right straight into a platoon
right into a platoon so they had just
got back from their deployment uh like
literally just got back so we rolled in
and I ended up in uh Charlie platoon
Seal Team seven and the platoon Chief
and the OIC in there were awesome
awesome two people that actually
genuinely cared about mentoring actually
cared about developing myself and the
other Squad commander and the other
Squad Commander had a big leg up on me
because he was Prior enlisted so he had
a lot of good experience he was a team
three guy a guy named Rob
um just a freak athlete too a guy that's
real easy to like real easy for guys to
want to follow good personality good at
everything he does but we had people
there that actually cared about
investing in US my first troop Commander
was Jack Carr who sometimes troop
commanders care about their squad
commanders and sometimes they don't and
Jack absolutely cared about us and we
were on training trips you know he'd
pull us aside talk to us and then also
just watching how he conducted himself
as a troop Commander being very
aggressive in a good way uh going
throughout training aggressively
maneuvering for us to get opportunities
overseas was really set our platoon up
for Success yeah yeah that's awesome I
remember putting Jack is uh
unfortunately for him or fortunately
depending how you look at it I put him
through as a platoon commander and then
as a troop Commander oh yeah so he was
stoked yeah
yeah we joke about that a lot I when we
went through the uh our first block of
training was land Warfare which is the
best place on the planet basically now
in California but I I was 25 I might
have just turned 26 so I'm kind of in my
Prime on this in my own mind this young
stud and we got through with land
Warfare and my knees weren't right for
like a solid two weeks like I remember
very distinctly going to church and like
you put the kneeler down post land
Warfare and I kneel down and I would
legitly didn't think I could get back up
afterwards so I'm thinking like I'm
looking at guys that have now done this
this is their eight land Warfare block
I'm like how the hell are these guys
still walking uh yeah but that was that
was it yeah that training was freaking
awesome
um
so what were you learning
oh man what were the big like so you do
you do land Warfare Mor Ops you know
Urban what what big what big Lessons
Learned do you have from a leadership
perspective yeah one of the things was
just letting the guys letting the guys
go so I was the class OIC for my sqt
class about halfway through the class
they fired the OIC that was there and
put me in charge so I got the
opportunity to run like a you know a
platoon quote unquote throughout sqt
land Warfare but we're all students
we're all learning stuff so it's not
like anybody has an advantage over
anybody else so I was a little bit more
Hands-On and very quickly into a platoon
you realize that's not
a solution for Success so we say one
your guys are going to tell you back off
and just let me do my thing but
um just being comfortable making an
initial call and then just letting them
do what they do was huge and I was very
fortunate I was in the squad with the
platoon Chief and I was very fortunate
that he I was making calls that he very
easily could have just said that's not
your job that's my job stop doing that
but he didn't do that he let me make
calls he let me learn he didn't let his
ego get in the way he was very
interested in in teaching me and
mentoring me
um so a big piece was just giving guys
Direction and then letting them go and
do that and then you didn't
decentralized command decentralized
command would be a huge thing yeah
decentralized command would be a huge
thing and another piece was just the
level of detail that goes into our
planning was very impressive for me I
always liked that aspect of things I
like kind of nerding out on the planning
style of the planning phase of the
operation but again my only experience
was sqt which your plans aren't super
robust so seeing the point man disappear
into his room and build routes where
like every single thing was taken into
account
seeing your snipers you know picking the
best places to be on the battlefield
based off the weapon systems they're
going to carry seeing your breachers
prep the charges they need for that
specific door and all those things it
was like oh the SEAL Teams are
everything that I was hoping that they
would be so the level of detail that
goes into the planning was awesome to
see and again it wasn't one person doing
that it was everybody had their role
everybody was contributing and then at
the end of the day you put all those
pieces together
I bet
that coming into the SEAL Teams
in like 2005 2006 2007 2008 2009 2010
2011 2012 like coming into if you're
showing up in the SEAL Teams during that
time frame
it was probably for all you guys that
showed up at that time it was probably
like yup
this is what I signed up for I came in
in 1991 and I joined the Navy 1990 I got
the Civil team one in 1991.
it was not what I thought it was going
to be you know like hey I thought I was
going to Vietnam but even even just
thinking that we would have like
you know areas to train thinking that
guys would be like hey this is what
we're doing that there would be this
extreme like Mission like there wasn't
no we weren't going to war I mean we're
going to do exercises you know like it
just wasn't
what
you weren't sitting in a room with like
like occasionally a Vietnam guy would
come in and talk to you occasionally
like Roger Hayden would show up and be
like you know you do some I ads and he'd
debrief you and you'd be like oh you
know that was awesome but most of the
time some guy that never done anything
not not to there not their fault but
they just there's no war going on in
1984. no war going on in 1987. oh yeah
sure if you guys went to Grenada if you
guys went to Panama but not any large
numbers and and so if you had someone
like that it was like luck most of the
guys never done anything and again no
offense and they did their best to pass
down but there just wasn't that attitude
either because you knew you weren't
going
you're gonna go on deployment go do
exercises yeah so yeah that J I can't I
can't imagine like for you You Know Jack
Carr's your your
your uh troop Chief or your troop
Commander I know who your platoon Chief
was I mean like you can't ask for a
better platoon Chief yeah like these
guys are focused yeah that had to be
freaking legit rolling in in 2010 I
thought like
the war is on yeah it was amazing that
environment is was prepped for us since
we went through buds because every
single instructor that was at buds had
multiple tours underneath their belt
some of them you know were dealing with
injuries that it had just come off the
battlefield and they had put him at bud
so for us like the the realization of
the second that you get to a Seal Team
odds are you're going overseas into a
combat zone now there's a couple of
platoons that don't you know there's a
couple tunes that go to the Philippines
and you know man that mission but the
odds were you were going overseas so
when you get into the training aspect
now of going through our our unit Level
Training blocks and prepping
it's utmost focused every because it's
real everybody knows that the second
that training's over with and you load
the bird up you're going to some place
where you're going to get after it yeah
I
I remember like I I would be teaching
Urban and I'd see like a guy in the
street like standing in the middle of
the street like a new guy like just
walking across the street or standing
and I would get like a knot in my
stomach I'd feel sick because I'd be
thinking like this guy's gonna get shot
like that's and that's just me right and
you had a whole I had a whole staff of
guys that were thinking that way so yeah
this was this was like a kind of a
really good time to be for you to be a
Young Junior officer and plus you're
older you know you're a mature you're
you're what did you say you were 25
almost 26 years the point time I was
probably 26. yeah so you're just you're
just in the perfect spot man it was
amazing I think probably the biggest
lesson learned for me going through that
initial training training blocks was
having high standard and then our
platoon commander and our platoon Chief
they had exceptionally high standards
and if we didn't get something right we
weren't going to bed like we were
staying out there and getting it done
and you know one night and specifically
just to kind of give an example of that
as you were back on San Clemente Island
going through the urban training and we
had just wrapped up the urban training
and now we're transitioning to the
maritime operation so boats in the water
coming in doing your OTB over the beach
type preparation that type of stuff and
uh big waves out there at the time of
year that we were out there
and we had a couple of guys who just
didn't prep their rucksacks properly and
they couldn't get through the surf zone
and our platoon Chief lost his mind and
we spent the entire night doing nothing
but swimming out past the surf coming
back in and swimming out past the surf
and at the time it was a miserable
experience but the next day you're like
there's a reason why we did that we
failed he has a higher standard and by
the way he was there with us swimming
through it wasn't like he was on the
beach you know giving us pointers with a
bullhorn he was leading us through the
surf zone again and again and again so
that mentality of you're gonna do it
until it's right layered on with the
fact of now we truly understand why
we're doing it until it's right because
overseas you only get one chance to get
it right so probably the biggest Lessons
Learned was when you hold a high
standard which our leadership absolutely
held high standards
guys don't complain about it yeah guys
like it guys love it guys enjoy being a
part of a platoon like that yep and
that's a perfect example of taking care
of your people and and not misconstruing
taking care of your people to be oh I'm
gonna let my guys get off easy oh hey
you know what it's no big deal if a
couple guys can't get through the surf
zone it's no big deal we still need to
get some sleep tonight it's like no
actually what's most important is you
know how to do your job and you're ready
uh so where did you guys end up going on
deployment it was all over the place for
a while because we were supposed to go
to Iraq and then we were going to go to
this new place called the crisis
response element and then we were going
to go back to Iraq and then about a
month before we actually deployed we
found out we were going to Afghanistan
which of course everybody was super
fired up about because at that point in
time Iraq was more or less shutting down
and Afghanistan was still rocking and
rolling so the unique thing about this
deployment is
in order to get they just switched the
concept up of how they wanted to deploy
the silver platoons into this they went
away from a regionalized perspective
where platoons were going to only deploy
to certain regions but what that meant
was the cycle of deploying platoons was
now going to be off and in order to get
all the platoons all the SEAL Teams I
should say back into
a cycle where it's predictable
deployments still team seven and
whatever our counterpart on the East
Coast was which I think was still team
10 had to do an 11 month deployment in
order to synchronize the schedule for
the rest of the for the rest of the
community
awesome so we get to go to Afghanistan
and we get to spend almost twice the
time in Afghanistan
and a unique thing about this was we
were doing a new Mission set over there
that was called Village stability
operations and the theory behind Village
stability operations was Afghanistan is
a is a wild place there's tribes all
over the place there's different
Villages that don't even know that a
central government exists there's just
all this tribal influence that goes on
and they wanted to be able to link all
of these tribes together basically into
one kind of cohesive central government
and how they wanted to do this was by
embedding Special Operations units
inside these villages
training up local police forces that
would eventually be able to provide
their own security once U.S forces
pulled out so that Taliban and
insurgents wouldn't just flood back into
the region the second that America
pulled out basically so our job was
going to be to embed in this Village
that no Americans had been in and step
one was clear white space and that's
kind of military terminology for there's
bad guys in this area the first thing
you need to do is get rid of them get
them out of this area because if you
don't you're not going to be able to
actually dedicate time to training
locals to be policemen because you're
just going to be fighting all the time
so step one was clear all the bad guys
out step two was build this localized
police force train them and then step
three was basically transition over to
giving them tithing tying all these
Villages into a provincial government
and the provincial government is now
tied into the centralized government so
our platoon and I think there was two
platoons from Team seven that were doing
that mission
are platoons and the sealed platoons
from Seal Team 10 were the first seal
platoons to do this Mission there was
different
varying levels of excitement about doing
this Mission because what do seals
normally do at least what do we think we
do when we go overseas direct action
we're just gonna find a bad guy we're
gonna kick the door down and we're going
to grab them or do something else to
them basically this was not this mission
on its face this mission was a buy with
and through mission
so there was the opportunity for guys to
not be very excited about doing this
Mission but because we had good leaders
and they really understood
all the opportunity that was layered
inside of that mission and all the
freedom that was layered inside of that
mission they did a very good job of
giving us the why behind things hey
we're going to Afghanistan here's the
mission that we're tasked with here's
why that's a good thing here's what this
affords us the ability to do as a
platoon so there were platoons that did
that mission that were not excited about
that because you're training people but
our leadership was
very creative they really understood the
mission which went a long way and they
did a really good job of not lying to us
about stuff but being honest and just
painting a picture of all of the things
that we could accomplish if we played
our cards right on that mission and it
was phenomenal I mean we within two
weeks of being in country
in Afghanistan we loaded up a convoy we
drove 300 miles away from the nearest
big American base which was mazari
Sharif up in Northern Afghanistan and we
embedded in a village in the middle of
nowhere like literally night one was
circle the wagons like Park your
vehicles in a circle stand watch and
you're just living basically out of your
vehicles as you're building up this
little fob in the middle of nowhere and
then we spent the next 11 months just
trying to build relationships with
different
uh tribes different locals and then
clearing white space out and uh
definitely some
probably the the biggest stark contrast
for me was
the perception of what
we were trying to accomplish versus the
reality on the ground over there so the
mission is you want to build this
infrastructure where you can tie these
Villages into the central government and
like that's going to be a really good
thing for them right well guess what
none of those Villages wanted they
wanted half of them didn't even know
there was a central government they
didn't know this guy Karzai who was the
president existed they're living
basically almost like in biblical times
out there where it's them their family
in this Village they're never going to
leave that Village they're hurting
they're growing uh crops they're going
to live they're going to die there and
everything is run internally to that
Village so part of this mission was we
had to conduct
all of these key leader engagements
which means you know let's say Echo is a
tribal leader we're going to go and do a
patrol into that person's village and
we're going to arrange a meeting where
we sit down with this tribal leader and
we explain to them why we're here as
Americans all the good things that we
want to do for you as Americans so we
would sit down in these kles and you
know sometimes it was my platoon
Commander doing them sometimes it was my
platoon Chief and sometimes it was me
just depending upon who was available
that day and my initial take was well
I'm just going to tell them all the
great reasons about why we're here you
know we're going to tie you guys into
the central government and it's going to
bring peace and stability and all these
things and they didn't want any part of
that and they would basically just turn
a blind eye or just boot us out of the
village so I had to change my tactic
so we would have these kles and you know
the new tactic that I chose was
you'll just tell them why we're really
there and see how that goes we're really
here because people that your country
was harboring flew planes into buildings
in my country and killed a lot of my
countrymen and we're here to find them
and guess what that resonated with every
single one of those tribal Elders
because that sense of honor and revenge
is built into a part of their culture
and we finally started to get some
traction the central government piece
the only people that cared about that
were people who realized they could line
their pockets by being involved with
that all the other Villages
they were down to support when they
understood that we were there for
basically Revenge sake
yes wild and one of the big Lessons
Learned I think from Vietnam Iraq
Afghanistan is you can't we can't try
and impose our way of life our values
our and our ideas on what they're on the
normal people there and and their own
government can't do that either by the
way like they're they're the people are
going to be who the people are and if
you're gonna try and do it it takes
generations to do it takes literal
generations to
to change the way people think and if
you want to take that kind of effort
then okay you can do that but it's gonna
it's gonna be an occupation where you're
going to have to set things up and run
things with a pretty Stern hand but you
know you can't just present these ideas
and people go oh okay cool your way of
life looks better than ours it just
doesn't work so don't try that
uh how was like what was the enemy
contact like where you're on this long
deployment yeah
um
at first outstanding from our
perspective right
so we when you go and you embed in one
of these Villages it's just a matter of
time like any vso site that we went and
talked to before or we were in contact
with them before we started to do this
Mission all said the same thing you're
going to embed out there you're going to
build up your little fob and then
they're gonna come they're going to come
and they're gonna try to push you out of
this fob they're going to try to kill
all of you and basically take that that
terrain back so within about
two weeks of us embedding might have
been three weeks of us embedding we had
a big coordinated base attack that went
down on our tiny little file when you
say bass like most people are thinking a
bass no we're talking
I don't even know if we were 100 100
square meters of terrain that we
possessed that our our camp was but we
had these two terrain features right to
our right and our left and we had built
these Ops up there where they were
constantly manned 24 7 heavy weapons
standoff weapon systems all that good
stuff so middle of the day all of a
sudden rounds start coming in inside of
the camp
mortar start coming in Rockets start
coming in and our camp was on the far
side of a Wadi which a Wadi for those
that don't know is a basically a dry
riverbed and on the back side of the
Wadi was all this High Ground because
it's Afghanistan it was basically the
beginning foothills of a mountain range
and they were launching this attack from
the back side of those mountains and it
was probably
700 800 meters so they were just lobbing
stuff in and as soon as it happened it
was very clear that that my platoon
Chief had thought through this exact
scenario because there was Zero
hesitation on the call it was load up
we're going and we're going to take The
High Ground away from those guys right
now
unfortunately for me I got stuck back on
the fob man in the radio because timing
wise my platoon Commander was at one of
these big kles somewhere else so my
chief pulls me aside as rounds are
coming in and he's like hey man I'm
sorry but you have to stay here and you
have to keep that radio contact going
with higher headquarters so they know
what's going on so my job during that
was basically communicate and then
coordinate our standoff weapon systems
why they maneuvered out through this
Wadi and then basically popped up on The
High Ground where the Taliban was not
expecting them to do they were expecting
us to just sit inside of this base and
try to Slug It Out with them and it was
very evident that they were not prepared
to get out flanked like that because
they our guys pushed them right off The
High Ground they got them on the on the
back slope of this mountain range there
was a Vineyard and they all hunkered
down in this Vineyard and then there was
a B1 flying overhead and we just reigned
thousand Pounders and 500 Pounders two
thousand Pounders and 500 Pounders right
on top of them as our guys were were
pinning them down and the whole thing
was over and probably an hour hour and a
half and that kind of set the initial
tone for deployment and then it was an
11 month deployment you're going through
Seasons you're going through summer
you're going through fall you're going
through winter
the the fighting season in Afghanistan
is real you know April starts the
fighting season because all the snow
melts people can move around and then by
about November when the first snow comes
the fighting season is basically over so
eight months of that 11 months was very
kinetic was an awesome time and then the
last couple of months were basically uh
dedicated to training
more or less because no one was out no
one was and there really just wasn't
that much of them left in our area
because we had done our job and cleared
them all out and built up the police
force to where now they had presences
inside of all these different Villages
and they were denying terrain to the uh
to the insurgents
what were your big Lessons Learned off
that deployment
big lesson learned one was
and I didn't really probably fully take
advantage of this or appreciate this but
my platoon Commander gave me so much
freedom on that deployment and we butted
heads a little bit during during ult but
he always looked out for me he always
had my back and on that deployment he
gave me a whole lot of freedom
to make some mistakes too and I made
some mistakes that could have cost the
platoon
some ability to maneuver with higher
headquarters and he took care of it for
me and he didn't you know beat me over
the head for it he just pulled me aside
and kind of talked to me about hey think
about this don't think about that you
know this is what you need to be looking
at from a perspective uh because it's
not just the fun of running around and
trying to chase down the enemy like we
have higher headquarters that you have
to appease and you have to have
relationships with him as well so one
was just
when I was a platoon Commander trying to
mimic that freedom to the guys that that
I was leading so from a professional
standpoint just giving your guys that
freedom a personal one for me was just
how quickly complacency can creep in
over an 11-month diploma especially so
for us IDs was a huge worry uh in this
area and it was a very effective weapon
system for the enemy very low cost and
within
three weeks of embedding we were doing a
convoy and it was nothing crazy it was
just a resupply convoy to go pick up
some more supplies because again we were
living in the middle of freaking nowhere
and we were driving down a road that
we've driven down a dozen times my
vehicle was the Third vehicle in that
Convoy and we hit a pressure plate and
it blew our vehicle off the road blew
the rear part of it out it was a
mat V is what they call it so it's a
mine resistant vehicle it was designed
to basically be able to take a blast
yeah thankfully better than a Humvee
right Humvee flat bottom blast hits it
all that energy gets dispersed right to
everybody that's inside of it really bad
day the matte V has a v-shaped hole so
when the blast goes off it kind of
redirects a lot of that blast energy and
we were in one of those and luckily for
us we hit it with a back wheel so most
of the energy was directed towards the
back end of the vehicle it blew the back
axle off it pushed us off of the road
but more or less everybody on the inside
was was just fine
uh wasn't an ambush or anything like
that I think they just laid it there and
left so within three weeks of being in
country
I'd experienced an ID and now I'm like
paranoid of IDs I'm dialed in like I
don't want that experience again we're
there for 11 months you're doing patrols
every single day
complacency starts to creep back in you
start to pay a little bit less attention
on your patrols to where you're where
your step in when you're dismounting
from your vehicle doing you know your
looks to make sure things are going on
you're starting to get a little
complacent
about halfway through the deployment
we had basically done all we could do
from our little camp we had cleared all
the white space out of there and there
was one Village left in our area that
was like the Taliban stronghold so what
we decided to do was
embed in that Village we were going to
do a big clearance operation clear them
out of that Village and then embed in
that Village and make their stronghold
our next vso site and if we did that it
was basically Checkmate for the region
like we now control all of the region so
it was a a big movement to get
everything we needed to do another embed
down there and also a clearance
operation at the exact same time
and the area that we chose to make our
HQ you know you're picking it off of a
of a map basically of satellite imagery
and there was a Schoolhouse that America
had built it's like the only concrete
building uh in the area and we had built
it I think in 2004. well the second that
we left that area the Taliban just made
it their HQ building no more school and
right before we went and did the
clearance operation uh we dropped a
couple of J dams on that building to
clear everybody out of there so we're
like this is the place we're going to
embed so my portion of this operation
was I was leading the embed team so the
clearance was going to go ahead and then
I was going to follow right behind and
we were going to seize that ground and
basically try to fortify it as quickly
as we possibly could and get ready to
repel enemy attacks so
it's about month six we get there and
when we get there the there's a big kind
of open area not necessarily a field but
just kind of probably an old playground
I would imagine right in front of the
school and we were told that it had
already been cleared of IEDs so we get
there I'm in charge I'm not thinking too
much about the IED threat because Army
had come through with our guys and their
EOD had cleared that entire area so my
thing at this point was speed we have to
get the weapon system set up we have to
get some of our barriers set up to
protect us that night when we know
they're gonna do a counter attack so hey
it's clear enough IDs let's get rocking
and rolling
um guys are starting to come in through
the side of the building and I'm trying
to make Communications with higher with
my platoon Chief and my platoon
commander and let them know we've
reached the schoolhouse and we're
starting the embed but we I don't have
satcom it's just not working so I break
out my SAT phone which almost always
works and I'm trying to get signal and
I'm just doing basically railroad tracks
in this front open space in front of the
school
trying to get a place that gets signal
and I finally get the signal and I can't
sit still for more than three seconds
anyway so like as I'm talking I'm
walking around this area that's out
front and I finally let them know what's
up hey we're here and then we start the
big movement I bring all the logistical
trucks in and we start actually
offloading the weapon systems and all
the things we're gonna need
about 10 minutes into that and it was
one of our local partner forces it was
his country stepped on a daisy chained
IED it was two 82 millimeter mortars
blew both of his legs off our two EOD
guys my Navy EOD guys were right on his
right side right on his left side and
they were miraculously uninjured but our
medic goes over there our seal medic and
starts patching this guy up
um gets the tourniquets on you know gets
the the fentanyl in them and then we
start to come up with a plan to call in
the hlz
my EOD guys because now there's an
active ID threat they clear a path to
the hlz which is only 100 meters away
from this building in that hundred
meters they found six more IEDs
over the next 24-hour period they found
a total of 16 IEDs right in that area
that I was walking around in not paying
attention to whatsoever so the reality
of it was complacency had creeped backed
in at that point in deployment and even
though
I had been told it had been cleared
before the right call would have been to
get my guys back in there and clear it
but I wasn't worried about that I was
worried about other things so
complacency is a real thing and you got
to keep keep watch on it at all times
all right so you come back from that
deployment and now you're rolling in you
did you go into another like a squad
command or do you go right to platoon
Commander I wouldn't write to platoon
Commander so I was very fortunate in uh
myself and two other guys that were
Squad commanders at the team asked to
stay at the team and go right into our
platoon Commander spot and we were given
the opportunity to do it so very very
rare I mean it's unheard of nowadays
because of the the officer pipeline that
we have but back then a couple of guys
would get the opportunity to stay back
and I was one of the fortunate three
that got to to stay back and do another
platoon and how'd you feel on this
workup and everything oh I my
expectations were very high you know we
did really well going through our our
first work up and things just kind of
made sense to me and I think a lot of
that was the mentorship that I received
from my platoon Commander my platoon
Chief there wasn't one area where I felt
like I really had some significant
struggles like land Warfare made sense
to me assaults made sense to me the
marops piece made sense to me so I was
expecting to go into ult our training
cycle and just you know completely blow
it out of the water do phenomenal and
part of the reason is I've been very
fortunate throughout my career to be
teamed up with very solid senior
enlisted and that was the case in this
one my platoon Commander tour as well my
platoon Chief a guy named Brian
phenomenal he's still in like awesome
tactician
um super humble guy kind of guy that
when he speaks everyone stops and
listens to what he has to say tons of
experience my lpo who's the second
highest ranking enlisted person inside
of the platoon was the the war com
sailor of the year just squared away at
everything he did and my fire team
leaders were good to go uh I had a bunch
of new guys so this was a 21 person
21-man platoon and of that 13 of my guys
were new guys so there's some challenges
there but also there's opportunity there
it means that we can raise them the
right way we can show them the things
that are important so I'm thinking we're
just going to go through this training
and just completely destroy it and our
first block again is land Warfare which
I love starting with land Warfare
because it shows you exactly what you're
working with from a platoon standpoint
shows you who you can go to who's going
to be there who's willing to you know
put in the work all that stuff so we get
there I feel very confident at land
Warfare so I'm thinking we're just going
to run through this training and it's
not what was happening and it was very
frustrating
we were not doing very well during the
land Warfare block and after about the
end of week two I'm kind of at my wits
end here and I can't really figure out
what the heck is going on and very
fortunately for me my first platoon
Chief is now running that land Warfare
block so he senses the frustration and
again you know he is very involved in
mentoring me throughout my entire career
and he pulls me aside after one of our
our afternoons of doing these immediate
action drills out in the desert where
things are just not going well and he's
like hey so
what's the deal and I didn't have an
answer I was just so frustrated I could
not figure it out I was like I don't
know like I feel like I'm making good
calls I just can't like we're just not
clicking and he's like well you're
you're trying to control too much and I
was
taken back I'm like well what do you
mean I'm trying to control too much and
he's like you're not letting your fire
team leaders you know make mistakes
you're not letting them take charge of
stuff like you're you see a mistake what
could potentially be a mistake and
you're jumping in and fixing it and I'm
like well of course
of course I'm jumping in and fixing it
like I'm the I'm the platoon Commander
I'm responsible for everything that's
going on in this platoon and you know in
my mind I didn't tell him this but in my
mind I'm like well if I if we make
mistakes the platoon looks bad and if
the platoon looks bad I look bad so I'm
trying to fix all these mistakes and
really what I'm doing is I'm just
hamstringing our entire platoon and
centralized command very centralized
even though I told you my last platoon I
learned all about the value of
decentralizing but then you have to
counter that with the ego that's like I
want to look good yes and I 100 did like
I wanted to our platoon to be the best
platoon I wanted to be the best platoon
Commander like I had you know my
personal goals here too but really I
wanted the platoon to succeed and we
weren't succeeding and I was the reason
and he said well hey
and this was probably not evident to me
at this point in time either because
again I only been in the community for
two and a half years at this point and
I'm in a leadership position now and he
said well why do you think we come out
here and train and I honestly didn't
know the answer to that I was like well
to prepare for deployment he's like and
what else I'm like uh to learn I'm like
and he's like yeah and he's like well
how do you learn he's like you make
mistakes man like your guys are here no
one in your platoon has ever been in the
position they're in right now you've
never been a platoon Commander your
platoon Chief as awesome as he is has
never been a platoon Chief your fire
team leaders have never been fire team
leaders you're all here to learn and
part of that is guys are going to make
mistakes and we make mistakes here so
that we don't make mistakes overseas and
by you stepping in every time you are
about to see a mistake or think you're
about to witness a mistake you're
cutting off all this learning and
they're basically being trained rain my
guys are basically being trained to not
do anything because LT will make the
calls and you can't see everything you
can't you don't control everybody and so
even though and the more they think
you're gonna control them and then you
can't or they're waiting and it just is
a disaster yeah absolute disaster and
that was textbook what was going on
inside of this unit Level Training block
but fortunately for me it was our first
block so I was able to course correct
and use decentralized command and start
giving the guys the room to make
decisions and guess what when they made
decisions ninety percent of the time
they made awesome decisions ten percent
of the time just like I would do 10 of
the time if not more I made bad
decisions and then we would debrief the
instructors would tell us the things
that went right the things that went
wrong we'd fix them and they wouldn't
happen again so by the time we were out
of unit Level Training we were doing a
phenomenal phenomenal job uh totally
prepared for deployment and five team
leaders were rocking and rolling lpo and
chief were never the the thing that any
of us were worried about we knew they
were going to be awesome but fire team
leaders are rock and rolling and my new
guys because we had so many of them they
were like the backbone of the platoon
you know they were running stuff they
were learning and we were totally
prepped for deployment and then where
did you guys go on deployment
unfortunately we did not go back to
Afghanistan and uh we did not go back to
Iraq I think actually Iraq shut down the
tail end of our very my first diploma so
we went to a place called the crisis
response element or the cree for short
and that's a place in the Middle East
that they stood up to basically be a
break glass in case of emergency type
scenario we'll have two platoons with
all this different capability there was
a boat team that was there there was a
tf-160th was there so they're basically
putting all these Assets in this central
location in the Middle East in case
another Benghazi happened which had
happened the year prior to to our
deployment so what everybody told you
about the cree was it's a great
opportunity like you're gonna go there
and you're going to be like the force of
choice if any contingencies happen
but the reality is nothing ever happened
so guys would go over there and they
would spend six months on this little
base and they would have to try to find
a way to make themselves relevant and
they really couldn't because there was
guys in Afghanistan that were doing
their thing and there was just not a lot
to do besides train and every now and
then you would go on maybe if you're
lucky one of these what they call uh
joint combined exchange for trainings or
jset and that basically means we would
go to let's say Lebanon and we would
work with the Lebanese seals and it
wasn't War but at least you were getting
to go someplace cool and do some
training that was like the highlight of
the cree tour so nobody was really
excited about going to the Korean not
going to Afghanistan but we had a great
platoon with great Dynamics and very
similar to the lessons I learned from my
platoon leadership in Afghanistan just
be honest with the guys odds are we're
not going to do anything but we're all
going to be together for six months
we're gonna train hard we're going to
improve our skills while we're here
we're going to be ready in case
something does happen and at the end of
the day we'll have a good time because
we're with each other and that's really
all that matters is we're all here
hanging out getting better together so
that's kind of the environment that we
rolled into but you guys end actually
ended up uh doing a pretty significant
support uh for another operation that
was going down we did we did and that
was definitely the highlight of that
tour and the way that we be we're able
to support that was through a
relationship so our troop Commander had
augmented this other command a couple of
times in his career and when we got into
theater he reached out to him and at the
time that particular command which was a
a tier one unit kind of a deploy for
purpose unit they were using Army
Rangers as their response Force if you
will so they would go and conduct an
operation and during the planning cycle
if they needed to call somebody for help
it was the Army Rangers basically that
they would call and they were building
them into their plan so he just called
them up and said hey I've got two
platoons of seals sitting right here in
this place what do you think about using
them as your support instead of the Army
Rangers and they were all about it no
knock on the Army Rangers whatsoever but
we all went through the same initial
selection pipeline we speak a Common
Language so they were very comfortable
with that so because the troop Commander
reached out made a phone call and
leveraged that relationship he had all
of a sudden we had an opportunity to
potentially go and get some work so the
unfortunate thing was not everybody got
to go down there and support and even
maybe not unfortunate but what was weird
was they didn't want to send just a
platoon down there either because they
didn't need 21 people so they wanted to
send about 12 people down there and they
chose guys from both platoon so wasn't
like hey Jocko take your platoon down
there it was hey we're just gonna pick
12 people and we're gonna send them down
there the initial idea was rotate those
12 people through but if you put
yourself into the the mindset of the the
people that you're supporting you don't
want that you want the same 12 people
the entire time so that you're getting
to know each other and know how you
operate so we ended up being down uh in
Africa for about four and a half months
of that deployment and there was lots of
different operations that they were
trying to tee up and the one that got
approved was actually the one that
probably had hands down like the highest
risk attached to it which blew my mind
like the other ones kind of seemed
relatively easy to go and accomplished
and for some reason this is the one that
got approved so we were what they call
the irf or immediate response force and
you know there's different lingo for
response forces and I don't know that
this is Doctrine but basically the way
that they described it was qrf means
you're like 15 minutes out type thing
irf is you're literally right there like
your stage ready to go on the X with
them and if something goes wrong you're
there to support so we were there irf
and it was a over the beach operation
which was phenomenal for us because
because we were deploying to the cree a
big portion of our training was focused
on maritime operations and over the
beach operation so we had prepared
extensively for over the beach
operations and now we were getting the
opportunity to go and actually support
which most people would probably think
well seals do otbs all the time but the
reality is we have not because we've
been engaged in conflict in Afghanistan
and Iraq so this was one of only two
over the beach operations that had
happened I think in like the last 15
years and we were getting to be part of
it and otbs are not easy
um there's a lot that can go wrong I I
did three shipboard deployments when I
was an enlisted seal or no two as an
enlisted seal one as an officer so I've
done like the so many OTB Ops it's
totally ridiculous when you're doing an
arc platoon we every op we would do
would be an OTB like we just go with TB
all the time it was and we got really
good at a core group of guys we just did
back-to-back uh ARG platoons and so we
were really good at it and it is
something that you really do
legitimately have to like practice and
rehearse like if you don't practice a
foot patrol
you know worst case scenario you you you
you know you get a half an hour lost and
you've got to walk back or you don't
practice
um
well Dives you also need to practice but
even diving is like you're kind of
contained like you have your rig you
have your swim buddy you go you don't
miss the target worst case scenario you
missed the target you swim back to the
extract Point man if you screw up OTB
like it's a disaster like boats are
sinking weapons are getting lost people
are getting stranded it's just it's a
total disaster so you have to be good at
it take some time to get proficient and
which running the training command you
see it even in training like guys are
losing weapons in training guys are you
know crashing boats in training even in
a very controlled environment so now
you're talking about a very complex
operation just in what they were looking
to accomplish and grabbing this one
particular individual off of a beach in
Somalia and now you're layering on the
most complex thing on the planet which
is the ocean and all the different
things that can possibly go wrong with
that and surprise surprise if it could
have gone wrong it went wrong on this
operation and I I can't get into too
much of the detail of it but the there
was phases to the operation so you can't
bring in a big Navy ship really close to
shore because people know you're there
now so you keep the big ship way off the
shore and then you launch in our smaller
fast boats you can't bring those fast
boats in too close because they're big
and loud and people can hear them so you
have to stop the fast boats at a certain
level and that's when you launch the
small boats The Zodiacs and then you
bring the zodiacs into a certain level
to a certain distance and then typically
guys are swimming in because it's dead
quiet so the plan was launch the fast
boats
to a certain point then launch the small
boats to a certain point and then the
assault force would swim in we would
stay about 100 meters off the beach in
our little Zodiacs and be prepared to
support the operation everything goes
great all we're doing is we're staying
right there and we're picking them up as
they come back out through the surf zone
in a perfect world so we launch the fast
boats and one of them hits a crab pot
out in the middle of freaking nowhere in
whatever sea where's you know we're
driving around in right now and it just
happens to be the command and control
boat so the Ground Force Commander is
inside and the Ground Force Commander
was the squadron commander of this unit
is in this boat that goes down so uh
obviously initial wrench in the in the
in the operation right there one of the
boat guys the guys that's driving around
the SWIC operator has to jump in in the
water at night time and literally pull
the prop off and put a new prop on to
get this boat back up and running
while that's happening the assault for
us is swimming in and by the time that
boat got back up and running they were
already embroiled in a massive firefight
on that Target so before guys even got
to the shore there was already things
that were going wrong
so the intelligence leading up to this
was that it was supposed to be uh pretty
permissive Target that this person was
an al-shabab operations facilitator he
was now retired which I don't know what
al-shabab's retirement package looks
like but they gave this dude allegedly a
little Chateau on the beach to live in
and uh he was definitely not retired he
was definitely still fully in the game
so the assault Force tries to get him
out and they're just receiving massive
contact from all over the place they're
exchanging fire they're trying to find
different ways to get inside this
building and they just can't do it
because we're not at war with Somalia we
can't actually bring a whole lot of
Firepower to bear so there's no overhead
air support which is very rare for U.S
forces to go into an area where they
can't drop bombs to mitigate risk so the
way that you typically from a risk
mitigation standpoint get to be able to
send 20 guys deep Behind Enemy Lines as
you've got a lot of assets overhead that
can keep bad guys at Bay well there was
none of that
so it was kind of like the Black Hawk
Down scenario where when the word goes
out in Somalia that people are here that
they don't like like they rally the
freaking troops and there was multiple
different groups of armed males making
their way towards this target while
that's going on uh we get the call to go
lock down the beach and make sure that
the beach is secure so that when the
assault Force comes off they don't have
to swim they can just load up and we can
get out of there because things are
getting sporty pretty quick
so on the way in
more issues start to have to happen
boats we have four boats with us uh the
small zodiac boats the rubber boats and
they're all just dying in the surf zone
on the way in and come to find out the
engines that they had in C in in theater
at the time that we were using were
these new electronic uh what do you call
Electronic
not carburetors but electronic ignition
engines so they had this safety feature
on it where if it sucked in sand into
the engine it would kill the engine so
you weren't cycling that sand through
the engine and burning it out well
you're doing an over the beach operation
in Somalia you're gonna hit soon you're
gonna hit some sand so all the boats are
dying guys are jumping out to try to
keep the boats from tipping over in the
surf zone because the worst thing that
can happen is your boat turns sideways
and it takes
a 10 inch wave to put that boat over
completely so guys are jumping in trying
to keep the boats in the right direction
we're trying to get the boats to the
beach and at this time the assault force
is you know coming off of that Target
and we're starting to receive uh some
pretty significant you know machine gun
fire I'm not convinced they knew exactly
where we were but I'm convinced that
they knew we were coming from the beach
somewhere so they were basically just
trying to spray the beach down so
um guys are coming off we're trying to
load guys up we're trying to get through
the surf zone the boat keeps dying some
boats have 15 16 people in them which
they're not meant to have 16 people in
them some boats have three people in
them you've got jet skis that are coming
in trying to pick guys up it was just uh
pandemonium but the the professionalism
of the guys that were on the target was
one of the most impressive things I've
ever seen with all that chaos with all
the contingencies going on they were
talking as calmly as you and I are
talking right now and even though they
didn't accomplish the objective
everyone came back which was a miracle
and there was a lot of really good
Lessons Learned From that operation but
it was
a very unique opportunity and the big
Lesson Learned was when you throw the
water in there if it can go wrong it's
going to go wrong yeah I was I was kind
of give water the credit for seals being
good because a lot of times we don't
have to work with the water we don't
have to work with the water everything
seems easy you know
um and for anyone else that tries to get
in the water and do their do this job
it's very very difficult
uh so you wrap up that deployment
um
and then then you go to buds right you
become a bunch of sports I went right
from there I actually asked I said hey I
want to stay at the team and do a troop
Commander tour and my EXO who was
awesome was like hey you're way too
Junior yeah to do a troop Commander tour
so you have to go somewhere else so I
wanted to go to buds because I knew
historically
if you're an officer at Buds and there's
a need at the team let's say someone
gets fired let's say someone gets
injured you can very quickly raise your
hand at Buds and say I'll go fill that
Gap so my whole plan was to go over
there it's not that I necessarily had
this overarching desire to be a budge
instructor it was
I know for a fact if someone gets fired
or someone gets injured and they need a
replacement they'll pull from from buds
pretty quick and I could get back to a
team quickly so I went over there and I
ran the third phase of buds which is the
last phase which is the the portion
where you're still selecting people it's
still very physically hard but now
you're actually teaching as well you're
teaching Marksmanship you're teaching
demolitions you're teaching very basic
uh land Warfare tactics and it was a
phenomenal tour I did not know that I
was going to enjoy it as much as I did
and a big portion of that was my crew
that I had were just a bunch of savages
they were just awesome like the epitome
of what you want of a Bud's instructor
they were all studs they were all you
know very physically imposing they were
all very good at the skill they were all
completely bought into teaching these
students and it was just an absolute
great time and you just you know
selfishly too you can actually spend
some time mentoring these young men
first phase not a lot of mentoring goes
on in first phase because you don't know
how many of those people are going to be
there at the end of that seven weeks by
the time they get to third phase odds
are
guys are going to graduate a couple of
guys might get rolled for land
navigation for safety but odds are the
officers coming through that program are
going to end up in the Seal team so you
can start really working with them and
investing in them did you work any hell
weeks while you were there yes every
opportunity was that like on the looking
at that from the outside
the thing that stuck out to me the most
was as a student going through it it
just seems like absolute chaos like
there's no Rhyme or Reason for anything
that goes on like it's just a
free-for-all it's the wild west
basically and then you get to see it
from the backside and everything is
organized and controlled down to the
smallest possible detail
it's meant to seem like chaos but
there's times and tables for everything
that goes on so from an instructor point
you know the stress level is
exceptionally high but it's also a very
controlled environment for safety's sake
because you're asking people to do some
pretty ridiculous things and you see
some gnarly things when you're going
through uh watching people go through
hell week as well like one student in
particular was dragging a little bit so
we brought him over and we put the pulse
ox on them and my medic pulls me over
and he's like hey man take a look at
this and I looked at his pulse ox and he
was at 46 percent
and I said there's zero percent chance
he's at four he'd be dead if he was at
46 so throw that one out grab another
one and bring it back over here do it
again 48 if you told that to a doctor
clinically that person is dead you can't
survive but somehow this dude was
rocking and rolling with 48 oxygen going
throughout his body and you know we very
calmly escorted him to Medical to get
examined and then within a few minutes
he was back out getting after it again
so the the the amount of things that
people can push themselves through is
just awe-inspiring when you're a student
you're going through you're just you
don't have that perspective I don't
think of really what you're going
through you know you're just getting
after it when you're an instructor and
you see what these guys are going
through it's it's impressive it's
awesome to see
did you get any better at uh figuring
out who's gonna make it
um
if it was a wrestler I'd put my money on
the wrestler if it was a guy that played
water polo I put my money on the guy
that played water polo uh I don't know
that I got any better at anybody else
but those two demographics for some
reason if you saw a guy coming through
and he had cauliflower ear I don't know
that I don't know that I saw one that
didn't make it through
um lots of different theories behind why
that is but I don't know that I got
better at picking I'll say this I got
better at identifying people that
wouldn't be there because the
instructors wouldn't allow them to be
there for much longer and that usually
had to do with their ego and their
attitude towards uh other people very
quickly you could pick out like this
dude is not going to last because his
people are going to turn on him and then
the instructors are going to make sure
that they don't make it through the
program which is a very good thing yeah
because these are people that are
concerned about themselves and not about
the team 100 and we don't want them nope
uh would you get what'd you do when you
got done with that so being a buds
instructor so
I was not quite through with my tour yet
but my master plan for going to buds
paid paid out so at the time there was a
need for another troop Commander at Seal
Team five and I was only about
16 months maybe into a two-year tour at
Buds and my executive officer was a guy
named Jimmy May and I asked him I said
hey I think there's a need at Seal Team
five for a troop Commander can I jump
ship early and go and he was like I will
never tell someone who wants to go back
to a platoon no so yes you can you just
have to convince the skipper and CMC
over there that they that they want to
on the team and uh one of the people I
had had the opportunity to work with at
Seal Team seven before Jason Gardner now
he's a team Echelon front
he was the CMC over there so it was a
pretty easy sale for me to slide over
there so I left buds early and went over
there as a troop commander and it was
just a phenomenal tour phenomenal tour
the entire team I think it was the first
tour that I had where it seemed like the
entire team was focused on the team and
not individual performances and you know
you go to a Seal Team you usually
there's three troops and usually what
happens is one troop is competing
against two troops which is competing
against three troops which is good you
want some competition but it can get
unhealthy you know one troop might not
share lessons learned from training to
two troop because they want to go to
Afghanistan so they want all the uh the
attention basically so even inside of
your troop sometime
you can have two or three platoons that
may be not really supporting each other
as much as they should there's too much
competition
I did not feel like team five was like
that at all I think that the commanding
officer and the CMC Jason set a real
good tone right off the bat of what we
expect is the entire team to act and
function as a team so it was the first
team I was ever at that the troop
commanders spent time frequently
together that the platoon Commander
spent time frequently together and it
really made a huge difference in just
the entire culture of that team and that
team my experience was everybody was
just fired up to be there everybody was
fired up to train and everybody just
wanted to go on deployment how was the
workup phenomenal so going through again
I was blessed with a phenomenal senior
enlisted advisor he actually just
retired after you know 20 plus years of
service and you know I felt again very
confident that we were going to go and
just crush this training my platoon
commanders were all phenomenal my
platoon chiefs were all phenomenal they
had all been multiple combats situations
I think you know just about all of my
platoon Chiefs just solid solid and we
got into unit Level Training and uh
first block of training was again land
Warfare which is awesome and at this
time we were transitioning as a
community away from training scenarios
that were more focused on fighting
insurgents and shifting into training
scenarios that we're more focused on
what they would call Great Powers
competition so people that have enemy
that have similar capabilities to us
think Russia think China they have Jets
they have night vision goggles they have
radios they can jam they can do all
these things so because
they were pretty confident the community
was pretty confident that our troop was
was a good troop they wanted us to go
through these ftx's first and experience
them as kind of a test before they
rolled them out to the rest of the troop
and we were fired up we're like heck him
and they think that you know we're the
go-toot for this like let's show them
what's up so again I'm I'm ready to just
bad setup you're such a bad setup right
so we're ready to just run through this
thing and uh I was the determining
factor in the fact that we were not
successful on the first FTX and I came
up with this plan that was just it was
too complex it was it was too complex
and I was nerding out over this
particular operation and I had you know
three platoons I had three platoons that
I could bring to bear on this
battlefield and I wanted to get a lot of
them out in the field and what that
meant was I just had too many positions
I had two positions in The High Ground
and then a third position that was kind
of in a decent piece of high ground and
in my mind that all made perfect sense
the reality of the situation was when
you go on a land Warfare FTX uh for
those of you who haven't been yet things
rarely go as planned and you're going to
receive contact and there's going to be
a lot of problems that get thrown your
way so the platoon that went in to do
the actual clearance and try to grab the
bad guy that we were after all of a
sudden they're embroiled in this massive
firefight you know situational awareness
is lost of what of where who is and they
come out of this uh this Village and
they're trying to extract with their
prisoner that they have now and they
just see muzzle flashes in multiple
positions in the mountains to include
bad guy positions that are up there too
and they engage one of the positions
that I had put out there that should not
have been out there uh Hey online or L
is the tactic and I violated that and we
paid the man for it that night and it
was a hundred percent my plan 100 I was
convinced like I'm like we got
everything locked down man like there's
no way anyone's getting in here and it
was just too much complexity for when
stuff hit the fan on Target and we went
back uh
guy that I really respect was running
training
um he just finished up his co tour I
believe at Seal Team seven phenomenal
guy and you know got a good honest
debrief
the master chief there that was running
training at the time again phenomenal
guy damn night guy
um solid professional and we got a good
hard honest debrief and the overarching
factor was my plan was just too complex
and uh if you guys can't understand what
you wanted to do they are not going to
be able to get it done especially ones
that Mayhem hits Mayhem once that Mayhem
hits man it's just everything's out the
window yeah and that's exactly what
happened hey everyone knew where those
positions were until the Mayhem hit and
until guys are now sucked into a fire
fight and there's multiple bad guys in
the Hills that are maneuvering as well
and they can't see us from the ground
they just see muzzle flashes and they
ended up engaging a position that I put
out to support and that Mayhem that plan
did not survive first Contact for sure
so we we being me course corrected uh on
the next two ftx's we came up with good
simple plans and we knocked an F2 next
to fdx's
out of the park and again I can't take
credit for that uh I had really solid
platoon commanders really solid platoon
Chiefs and all I had to do was give them
a good plan that was not too complex and
just let them execute on those plans and
I say give them because these were troop
size ftx's these weren't platoon size
ftx's so every FTX was a troop size it's
kind of cheating
yeah like when I was a troop Commander
when I was platoon Commander it felt
like I was kind of cheating because
people would see like why aren't you
gonna put this you know integrate your
fire teams and mix them up and I don't
know what you're saying with our normal
fire teams and well don't you want to
put someone over here nope we're not
doing that and it was so we get out
there and Mayhem would happen would we
just be all in our standard operating
procedures it wouldn't have to change
anything and it was like
kinda easy I remember when I first
started when I wrote down like the laws
of combat right and I didn't reference
those off of anything I didn't refer to
any manuals I just was like I know you
know you've heard the story but I was
out there at our land Warfare training I
was watching the Splatoon fall apart I
was like okay I can see what they need
to do they don't know how to lead here's
what they need to do I didn't go back
and cross-reference like any of the war
fighting manual from the Marine Corps or
FM 7 attack 8 from the from the Army I
didn't do any of that I just took what I
had what I knew
and then
you fast forward like six months and I'm
like hey you know I need to like make
sure
that I what I'm putting out is solid
right
and one of the first things I felt like
I kept telling everyone like hey you
need to keep you simple you need to keep
it simple you need to keep it simple and
it turns out that's literally the oldest
maximum of the oldest maxim of military
leadership is keep it simple that's like
number one you can look at any you know
Canon of military leadership and how to
conduct operations it's like you better
keep it simple and it's literally like
cheating you go out on these crazy
operations but everyone's just doing
what they've been doing for the last
three months or the last three weeks and
everyone knows their fire team and they
know what the objective is and they go
do it no Factor keep it simple yeah the
next two fdx's were simple online L
clear and surprise surprise things went
well awesome uh anything else on that
work up
um the big thing that stuck out to me
was
we knew that there was going to be the
potential that we could be clearing Isis
out of mosul on that deployment
so the battlefield had changed
tremendously from the I guess
technically the second Iraq war that you
guys weren't involved in uh we were now
not necessarily it was it wasn't our
fight it was the Iraqis fight we were
going to be enabling them with
capabilities we were going to be right
there uh beside them you know with them
inside some of that fighting but it was
going to be their job to clear those
people out it was also exceptionally
micromanaged the campaign was so we knew
that we were going to be working with
army Personnel Marine personnel and we
knew that we were only going to get
basically one chance to impress upon
them our level of professionalism so a
big thing that was important to my SCA
my senior enlisted leader and I was
making sure everyone in our platoon
understood why we needed them to look
professional and act professional why we
needed them to be clean-shaven when they
get overseas why we needed them to be in
a proper uniform maybe even more
importantly than that why we needed them
to be able to understand what
operational terms and Graphics were
which for people not in the seal
Community nobody cares about those in
the seal Community luckily because I had
such good leaders at the platoon level
we only had to say it once and then they
took it upon themselves and carried that
message and the overarching why we gave
them was we're not guaranteed there's
other units in theater there's Marines
in theater a Mars oxygen theater you
know Army's in theater and there's you
know just because you have a trident on
your chest doesn't mean that you're
going to be the force of choice to go
into mosul like the opportunity is there
but we have to be able to take advantage
of that opportunity so not only were we
focused on training but guys really had
to be focused on
the professionalism aspect of it and it
was easy it was easy and I think the
reason it was easy is because I had such
good leaders at the troop level and they
really understood and owned that message
and guys want to go fight and if the
price they have to pay to go fight is a
clean shave and a scored away uniform
and and looking at the you know small
unit tactics manual every now and then
and that's what they were going to do
FM 101 tac-5 tack one no operational
turns and terms and graphics
it was crazy that we would brief senior
leadership in the Army in the Marine
Corps utilizing what symbols we thought
made sense to us just like arrows yeah
like a boxes yeah like just just like
random whatever we thought worked and
man when I figured out like oh
the Army in the Marine Corps actually
and actually all NATO forces followed
this manual right here okay cool I got
it that was a huge step forward in life
yeah it was like learning to speak their
language in a in a split second because
you always just pulled that book and you
can figure out what you're supposed to
be saying
um and then how'd that deployment go oh
it was phenomenal phenomenal I'll just
start off by saying I didn't do anything
on that diploma my role as a troop
Commander was going to be back uh in the
rear basically with the command
structure you know supporting and
enabling my guys there just wasn't a
role for the troop Commander to be in
the field at that point in the in the
war and you know that was fine you know
I had two great deployments where I got
to have some fun and now it was my turn
to watch my guys go out there and watch
all their hard work pay off uh I think
our job was done our heavy lifting for
my my troop Chief and I was done during
ult it was making sure that they were
trained up as well as they could
possibly be because we knew that we
weren't going to be out in the field
with them
are there opportunities to get out for
an operation or two and go see your guys
and have a good time yeah but I'm not
going to be the Ground Force Commander
for these operations my platoon
commanders were going to be the guys
leading the fight and
because of the level of professionalism
that our whole team had and because our
commanding officer and our Command
Master Chief had this vision of how they
were going to make themselves the force
of choice for the mosul clearance
our guys became the force of choice for
the mosul clearance which should not
have happened the Marines were actually
controlling so for those that don't know
mosul is in Northern Iraq it's a big
city half of the city is very
Metropolitan very very well it was very
new and the other half of the city is
what they call Old mosul it kind of
looks like uh it was built probably in
the 1800s type thing mud Huts that type
of thing so the Marines were given
ownership of the battle space up north
so mosul is in the north so the the
Clear Choice
when you look at it should have been the
Marine should have been leading the
charge into mosul our commanding officer
did a phenomenal job of training us and
preparing us and selling our capability
and because he did that and put in all
the work building relationships with his
his commanding uh the command structure
inside of Iraq before deployment even he
was able to convince them that actually
the capabilities that we bring to bear
are more suited for that campaign than
the Marines were look nothing against
the Marines we just had a commanding
officer that was very good at selling uh
our capabilities in building that
relationship and because he could do
that our guys were the ones that went uh
inside mosul so I gained two more
platoons for deployment because there
was so much work to be done inside of
Iraq
I went through work up with three
platoons and then at the end of our unit
Level Training cycle our big training
block I was given two extra platoons to
go and deploy with so I was going into
Iraq with five platoons those five
platoons we split up into seven
different out stations so spread them
all across the country and each of their
jobs was basically clear Isis out of
your space that you're in and a big
piece of that ended up being mosul so
most of the time energy and effort got
spent in clearing mosul and again I
wasn't up there you know I let my guys
run the show they were well trained you
know they knew what the mission was I
got to go out a couple of times and have
some good times with them but it was
them leading the fight and they did a
phenomenal job an absolutely phenomenal
job and by the time our deployment was
over our guys had completely cleared all
of uh Eastern mosul so sorry yeah
Eastern mosul the the big city crazy
Urban combat you know Isis that was
their caliphate at that stage in the
game they had put all of their Fighters
inside that City and they plus them up
when they knew that the clearance was
coming they would send fighters from
Syria to plus this up so now you know
imagine you're clearing through this
city with skyscrapers and it's
completely controlled by three to four
thousand Isis Fighters that are inside
of there and because they had the whole
city controlled before we pushed in they
were doing things like staging these
giant suicide vehicles in all these
different garages so you would be
clearing and then all of a sudden two
blocks ahead this something that looks
like something out of you know Mad Max
you know Fury Road would come out and it
would just Barrel towards you and you
would have 15 seconds to get a rocket or
a bomb on that thing and if you didn't
it was going to level up a city block
and that was every single day for about
the last four months of that diploma is
the environment that those guys were out
there and operating in and every single
one of the platoons that we deployed
with had the opportunity to get in a lot
of good kinetic operations on that
deployment which that was unheard of in
2015 and 2016. we had gone through three
or four years where guys just weren't
getting to actually do the job overseas
and we were very fortunate and I think
we were able to take advantage of the
position that we were put in to actually
go overseas and do some good work
and you guys lost one of your EOD guys
right we did yeah only guy that uh
didn't come back so
uh JJ fine and he was our EOD Chief
phenomenal dude he was embedded with one
of my platoons that was on the outskirts
of mosul so they were up at this place
uh the mosul we call the mosul dam house
there's a giant Dam up there and one of
saddam's old palaces was up there and we
took it over and we were running
operations uh out of there and they were
running into IEDs left and right up
there and they were also running into
like chemically laced IEDs so our EOD uh
capability needed to be at this one
particular site and the the the day that
we started the push for mosul and I say
the push for mosul because we actually
had to get to mosul to start the
clearance so we were probably you
imagine almost a World War II scenario
where there's no joke a forward line of
troops we would call a flot and good
guys on this side bad guys on this side
and you would go to that flot and you
would just exchange fire all day long
and try to get to a position where you
could push the flot forward at the end
of the day and then just do that day
after day until you actually get to
mosul to start the clearance so the very
first day that the clearance kicks off
uh our guys are embroiled in you know
massive firefight at one of these
forward line of troops and uh they
realize that they're getting maneuvered
on and they can't really stay in the
position that they're in so they make a
call to get in their their up armored
vehicles and go to a more tactically
advantageous position to continue the
fight
they realize as they started to do that
my EOD guy JJ the chief was in the front
seat of the front vehicle because it's
his job to try to spot things right and
he realizes pretty quickly that the
route they chose took them right into a
Minefield basically so he calls an
all-halt and now they're trying to
figure out how they're going to get out
of this Minefield so hey safe in safe
out right and what that means for people
not in the military is if you walked in
a way it's probably pretty safe to
assume you can walk back out that way uh
much less risk than continuing to go
forward or try to go left and right
because you've already tried that path
once so he's in the vehicle he makes the
call to you know all back so to back
everybody up and the platoon Chief is in
the back of the vehicle and he's got his
door to the mat V open and he's trying
to make sure that they're following the
exact same uh tire track that they were
in before and JJ's kind of directing the
entire thing and he sees uh the platoon
Chief with his door open and he says hey
man close your door like that's my job
so platoon Chief closes his door JJ
opens his he's looking down trying to
spot and I don't know if they had just
barely missed it the first time or if it
was a crush play plate and a crush plate
is a tactic the enemy will deploy where
they will build a charge and they'll
attach a pressure plate to it that has
to have basically so much poundage
um before it detonates so like you've
got these two different connectors and
you know someone steps on it and it
pushes it down a little bit more someone
else steps on and it pushes it down a
little bit more and the reason that's a
great tactic is if I hit the first guy
in the platoon everybody else can stop
and pull back if I hit the seventh guy
in a platoon now everybody's in a really
bad scenario so a crush plate is is
probably what it was and as they were
driving back over that they detonated it
and JJ was looking right down at the
charge and uh you know it did him in and
our guys tried to keep them alive they
were working on them
um after all of this went down after the
bomb goes off uh all the guys in the
vehicle are clearly you know their bells
are wrong but like they're going to work
they're trying to save them they are
able to keep them alive for a pretty
decent period of time but there's no
hope man he's he's gone and by the time
they get him to the uh the the hlz to
get him out of the Medevac bird he's not
responding he's he's he's gone
um uh I was was one of the days that I
was actually fortunate enough to be able
to go out with one of my platoons I was
my another platoon Charlie platoon and I
were out at another point in the forward
line of troops and I was having the best
day that I'd had on deployment so far
because I was finally
out of the office with my guys in the
field we were exchanging it a little bit
with the Isis guys on the other side of
the flight and we were having a good
time and I was just loving being back
with the guys and then I get the phone
call
and you know as a leader whenever you
get we always have our satellite phone
with us so that you have multiple layers
of communication right you've got your
satellite radio your personal radio the
vehicles have radios all of this is
meant to be sure that you can reach
people no matter what's going on
when the satellite phone goes off
usually what that means is they're
purposely choosing not to communicate
over the net that everybody in theater
can listen to so I feel the vibration in
my pocket and I'm already got like the
pit the pit feeling
took the phone call it was actually one
of your one of your guys that told me
and went from best day to worst day
foreign
how long was that um
how long were you guys you know actively
fighting in mosul
the last four months of the diploma was
every single day inside of mosul every
single day
and then what was the turnover like when
you were turning over we were turning
over for hey you guys are gonna go and
do what we were doing that's exactly
right and just fortunately the turnover
happened at the best possible point in
the clearance it could which is we had
just finished the eastern part of the
clearance we'd reached the river and now
Seal Team seven came in behind us and it
was their job to finish the clearance so
we had reached this perfect Landmark to
do that turnover so they were there for
a couple of the days
uh prior to that so they got some good
experience in they got to see what our
guys were going through and then we
turned over to them and they got to take
care of the western part of mosul and
clear that up and they finished that
clearance on their diploma and once that
was done uh Isis was crushed I mean they
were more or less crushed by the time we
had rolled out not because we you know
I'm not saying we crushed him but I'm
just saying their foothold in mosul was
gone they weren't getting it back so
still team seven came in awesome to Horn
for them too and and finished uh
finished it up the thing that was crazy
to me about that deployment was
at times the level of micromanagement
that was going on my platoon Commander
that was in mosul every day had to have
a I shouldn't say had to we chose to put
it in there he had a phone line in his
Matt V and his command vehicle that went
directly to the one star Commanding
General of the theater that's the level
of intrusiveness that was happening on
the battlefield now
because we had such good leadership in
our commanding offset and our our
Command Master Chief
we embraced it we embraced it and they
said look guys this is going to be the
reality and you can do what other
platoons have done and what other units
have done which is push back against it
and guess how far that's going to get
you or you can embrace it and you can
give them everything they want before
they need it and that's the best chance
you have at getting a little bit of
Freedom so we went into the one Stars uh
jock they're basically a tactical
operations center and we gave them every
piece of equipment we had to allow them
to battle track us and then we put the
phone line inside which you know Bain of
that gfc's existence but it was in there
and it was his job to monitor that phone
line and if there was questions directly
from the one star he was going to be the
one that needed to field that question
and put that one star back in their
comfort zone so that we could continue
the clearance and the choice was pretty
clear you can either push back against
it and you you can see how that works
out for you or you can just embrace it
and because we chose to embrace it we
had more freedom to maneuver than
anybody else did now eventually what
happened is
the I believe it was the two-star
Commanding General the entire campaign
came and visited my guys in the field in
mosul and he saw the process and he said
this is ridiculous and almost overnight
the authority to release Munitions from
aircraft went from the one star to the
guy on the ground
so overnight change and that was based
on the fact that you had a leader a two
star who wanted to see what the reality
was in the field and was not happy with
what he saw and he changed it up and
that was the real game changer for mosul
the first month of mozul the Iraqi
Special Operations forces were getting a
trident so fast that we thought the
campaign was over we thought that we
were going to lose part of that was they
were not necessarily employing the best
tactics and part of that was it took so
long to get a strike off and when you're
dealing with multiple suicide Vehicles
bearing down on you at any given time
you can't hesitate with that stuff you
don't have time to call and paint a
crystal clear picture so a big piece of
it was the Iraqi started listening to
tactics that our guys were telling them
to employ and an equally big piece of
that was finally our guys on the ground
had the ability to conduct business the
way that it needed to be conducted and
they took full advantage of it yeah you
gotta when you're in a leadership
position you got to go out and see
what's happening on the grounds that's
all there is to it and if you're not
doing that and you're looking at it from
a distance man things just look
different from a distance and they might
even seem like they're squared away yeah
you know the process when you look at a
flow chart that someone's presenting you
on PowerPoint of how the fires are
getting approved you're like okay this
probably takes five minutes you know
this probably takes three minutes that's
no problem first of all you don't
realize how long three minutes really is
and you also don't realize that three
minutes is really 30 minutes
so and this applies to anywhere this
applies to businesses applies to
everything that's going on from you from
your leadership perspective you have to
get out and actually go down and see
what's happening and if you don't do
that there's going to be problems you
have no idea what's going on no idea
um you get done with that deployment
now you you come back and what you step
up to opposite still looking fine yeah I
did I did not want to leave the uh the
Seal team I loved everything about Seal
Team five
um I asked another troop Commander
because I was still pretty Junior for a
troop commander and they said no so I
said okay cool Ops and uh they said sure
you can stay around that Ops and I mean
you know Ops is not usually a job that
people are super excited to do in the
SEAL Teams there's a lot of maybe bad
stigma that comes with the Ops jobs and
just the fact of how many hours you're
going to work and you're not with the
guys and you're going to be doing some
admin type stuff and the reward the
rewarding feeling is maybe not as high
as as other tours
I loved it I loved it for a couple
different reasons I had a phenomenal
commanding officer and a phenomenal
Command Master Chief and that commanding
officer gave me a whole lot of room to
run the day-to-day of that command and
you know he led by commander's intent
hey here's what I want to have happen
and I would go and I'd build out some
some courses of action for them and then
I would brief him I'd tell him which one
I thought was the best one and 99.9 of
the time he would say cool go execute uh
I also had very good senior enlisted it
was my counterpart my Ops Master Chief
was another phenomenal guy who you know
knew a lot more about the operations
role than I did because I'd never been
in it before so he you know helped me
out keep me in line kept me pulling in
the right direction and then again we
were blessed with really good troop
commanders who made my life very easy
and really good platoon commanders who
made my life very easy and uh
unfortunately I did not get to deploy
with them because I got pulled to go to
the the training command which was
awesome but always a bummer to miss out
on deployment especially when you have a
team that you just love and in the
operations job when you're in the
training cycle it's not super rewarding
you know you're putting training
together you're running the command on
behalf of the of the CEO day-to-day
you're piecing all those things together
you're prepping for deployment then you
get on deployment and as an operations
officer that's where you can potentially
have a little bit more fun if there's a
strike sale in theater you'll probably
have a hand in running a whole lot of
those strikes so I was very much looking
forward to deploying uh and getting the
opportunity to to run the strike sale
and also just I loved everybody at the
command and I didn't want to to leave
that command but I was called up to go
to the training command which was
awesome I just wanted to do it six
months later I didn't want to do it
right then and right there yeah I want
to make a quick note you're talking
you've been talking about your career in
most the vast majority of your career
you've had a lot of autonomy and been
able to do a lot of things and that was
very similar to my career
um but I would say because I was kind of
you know tracking your career you know
first of all when I was putting you
through training and and then you know
through disguise that I would talk to
and what what team they're not what
platoon how they doing
you were squared away
and when you're squared away
things are a lot easier when you're
squared away you get a lot more leeway
when you're squared away when you do a
good job when you're professional when
people can trust you when you're when
your boss trusts you when the Ops Master
Chief when the Ops officer when the EXO
when the seal when people trust you
you can do you can do a lot more and
it's all those little things that you
mentioned it's you know making sure that
everyone's professional but it's also
like hey doing a good job during
operations and when you screw things up
saying hey this is my fault here's what
we do to fix it like all these things
are what lead to freedom and and having
this autonomy there's I always say if
you talk to most of the people that ever
worked for me they'd be like oh freaking
Jocko's like he'll let me do whatever I
want like he was just he let me do
anything anything I want to do let me do
it there's a few people that were not
squared away and if you said oh how was
it working for Jocko they'd be though
he's a complete micromanager
there's a reason I'm micromanaging if
I'm micromanaging you there's a reason
why I'm micromanaging you
and I just wanted to point that out you
know you had a great reputation of being
squared away of being professionals
getting the job done of making good
decisions and that gives you a ton of
leeway and look can you get a
micromanager that's like doesn't matter
what you do they're gonna micromanage
you yep can you be in a situation where
like you're talking about the beginning
of that deployment the first month where
book The even the you know we talked
about a platoon Commander never being a
platoon Commander before and uh and a
platoon Chief never beaten well
whoever's in charge during the initial
assault of mosul they've probably never
been in that hey we're gonna go assault
uh do a Siege assault on a city they
probably never been in that position
either so they're doing the best they
can they didn't quite figure it out so
the only thing they know to do is just
like control kind of like when you were
at at land Warfare as a troop commander
and you're like or as a platoon
Commander I think you said and you're
gonna control everything there was
probably a leader there thinking I'm
gonna control everything I gotta make
sure that we don't make any mistakes I
don't want to have any of this I don't
have any of that so they get very in the
micromanagement mode and something
happens to happen where they can
readjust their mindset in this case two
star flies out looks at what's going on
the ground and says this is not right
and then put some trust back in the
troops on the ground but I just wanted
to point that out if you as a person
listen to this or feel like you're
getting like man oh I heard Sean glass
you got to do whatever you want I'm
gonna tell you Sean glass earned the
right to do whatever he wanted he earned
that freedom and if you're feeling like
you're micro getting micromanaged it's
not the responsibility of your boss to
figure out that you need more freedom
it's your job to prove to your boss that
you're going to make good decisions that
you're going to be professional that
you're gonna when something goes wrong
you're gonna take ownership like all
these are important lessons and you've
kind of you've kind of spelled out
almost like a fantasy career of I got to
do what I want I got a lot of leeway I
got this I got that I mean getting you
had you already got three platoons as a
troop Commander then they gave you five
platoons as a true creator that's not
normal they had a huge amount of trust
in you as a leader to step up and be
able to do that so I just wanted to
point that out if people if you're
listening to this and you're thinking
man that guy had great bosses he didn't
get micromanaged I'm gonna tell you Sean
earned that right to not be micromanaged
and I think that's an important thing to
point out
um you get done at Team five now you go
to trade at you're in the best what I
believe is the best leadership lab in
the world hands down I don't think
there's anything better than trade at
for seeing and watching and learning and
understanding leadership I don't think
there's anything close to it and you're
in a position where you get to see
leadership in action on an almost
nightly basis you get to see leaders get
put in
through a scenario and the next night
you get to see other leaders get snared
through that same scenario and the next
week you get to get see other leaders
get put through that same scenario so
you're seeing like iterations of
leadership and you'll start to learn
what works and what doesn't and it's a
uh it's a very powerful I think it's the
best leadership lab in the world I I
think you are 100 right and something
that's a testament to that is
when you are the officer in charge of
that training command there are
professional sports teams that want to
come and talk with you and your staff
about how you organize training you get
authors that are writing books about
leadership that want to come and see
what's going on the Red Bull training
team came out there to see what was
going on like
is hands down the most unique leadership
lab on the planet and we spend so much
time and money as a community training
and the scenarios that we develop like
it's testing every single piece of that
platoon from The Troop commander who
maybe has four deployments to the
platoon Chief who maybe has six all the
way down to that brand new machine
gunner every single FTX is testing every
single skill set for one of those
individuals
when you what was the biggest or you
know what was it would you take away
from it two biggest takeaways from a
leadership perspective one is if you
came in there with a big ego from a
leadership perspective you your people
were gonna suffer your people were gonna
suffer for six months if you couldn't
freaking uh change that and that I'm not
saying
I'm also not not saying this but I'm not
saying that was because my guys would
hone in on you and Crush you I'm saying
that because you would fail to take on
the lessons learned and if you're a
platoon Commander or a platoon Chief
that's not accepting those Lessons
Learned you're making the same mistakes
which means every night is a rough night
for your platoon and we saw plenty of
platoons you feel bad for these guys
where every night is a rough night for
that platoon and it's 100 on that on
that leader and one of my favorite
experiments to run and I'm sure you did
something similar was uh sometime in a
scenario I would eventually not every
night but every platoon Commander that
came through got this at least once when
I was there uh I'd kill them in a
scenario we'd be doing these big ftxs
and I put them down and I wanted to see
what was going to happen and typically
one of three things would happen one
everything would just grind to a halt
everything would grind to a halt no one
would make a call no one would want to
make the next decision everybody would
just kind of freeze and what that tells
me that I need to talk to that platoon
Commander about is just he's
micromanaging the same thing I was doing
as a platoon Commander he's
micromanaging his people are afraid to
make that call the second thing that
happened is hey everything went great
guys picked up the slack they covered
they you know they covered a move for
each other they got the job done and
what that told me was the guy did a
great job of decentralized command that
his people knew what was up and they
were not afraid to make decisions the
one that was always my favorite to watch
is
we would remove the platoon commander
and everything would just get so much
better just so much better and that
tells me that person was just a freaking
egomaniac just a hurdle just get that
person out of the way and let the
platoon do what they know is right yeah
yeah it's crazy to watch and you could
do the same thing like uh you might have
a super strong platoon Chief and it'd be
the same thing you kill him and
everything grinds through halt or you
kill him and people eat people start
stepping up you know it's just you got
to do those things and you definitely
learn and the ego thing
most vast majority of the time guys
would they would get they would they
would take the lessons on board they'd
be like yeah we sucked last night God
that was horrible I'm embarrassed you
know I can't believe we did that and
over you know five fdx's
by the fifth one the land Warfare Cadre
can't beat the tap the task unit anymore
they can't beat the troop anymore
they're too good they maneuver too quick
they're covering for each other they're
keeping things simple they prioritize
like they're just executing and you
can't there's nothing you can do about
it which is great that's what we've
always wanted to see it was weird
sometimes
you'd get a platoon or a troop that
would think what you wanted them to fail
which is the craziest thing in the world
you're like bro you're my friend like I
grew up with you I want you to win dude
but you can't do this dumb you
can't do that you gotta stop doing that
um but vast majority of the time they
were learning and it was great I one
thing that I'll never forget is seeing
guys like have an Enlightenment yes
right seeing like a troop Commander or a
platoon Commander or a platoon Chief or
just seeing them have like an
Enlightenment and they would go from
literally being a bad leader
and they'd figure it out and then they'd
become a good leader like almost
instantaneously that was always awesome
to see uh but
man the experience that you get from a
leadership perspective at that in that
trade-out position I was so lucky
because when I was in E5 I was at Seal
Team one and I was in training cell and
I was teaching this is before there was
sqt so I was teaching like new guy
officers who were taking them out with
the new guy enlisted guys and we'd go
out and I would be doing hiats with them
and like I'd be detached and I would see
what it looked like and I would see it
will work and what didn't work so by
that time I was an officer like I had
already done like what well the
equivalent of a trade at tour yeah it's
freaking so lucky yeah so lucky the word
that you just used the Detachment piece
was the second big lesson learned which
is the second usually that's the light
bulb moment yeah oh for sure is when
they realize hey I I have to detach from
what's going on right here from a
leadership perspective I can't be the
person that's patching up the wounded
people uh all of a sudden things would
get a lot better for that entire entire
platoon entire truth yeah and usually it
would take a pretty rough night before
you could convince him like you gotta
step back some people are harder than
others and they wouldn't learn quite as
quick but hey when you kill them yeah
and all of a sudden they're alive and
they're just sitting there listening to
what's happening they're watching and
the all of a sudden the answers become
very clear but they're not allowed to do
anything about it and I remember so many
guys would be like this is what you
should be doing you see how you know
what's going on you see how you're
monitoring this you see you see how you
see what they should be doing right he's
like yep you didn't know that three
minutes ago yeah because you were
freaking clearing rooms like an idiot
you shouldn't be clearing rooms you
shouldn't be working on that one guy you
shouldn't be handling these prisoners
all that stuff that you're doing like
how many rounds do you have how many
mags do you have left I have two mags
left out of nine wrong what are you
doing bro stop yeah you're a leader
yeah I was fortunate enough to learn
that lesson uh early on the ability to
detach and that was one of the things
that I would always try to impart on
leaders people in leadership positions
as quickly as I could so when I was
running third phase and we were exposing
these young officers to tactics for the
first time we'd run these immediate
action drills and they would just be
nightmares they won because they're just
learning but two because they would
shoot
seven out of nine Max and then the next
round that we would go I would talk to
him uh in between runs and I would just
say hey look man your job is not to do
that your job is to maneuver the platoon
you have a platoon that's your weapon
system your weapon system has a seal
platoon Commander is your platoon it's
not your rifle and get comfortable with
that and then we'd let them go again
some guys got it some guys didn't and if
they didn't the next run I would take
their gun yeah and yes guess what would
happen the second I would take their gun
all of a sudden they're making good
calls because they're not worried about
seeing the world through a rifle scope
anymore and it was the same thing at
trade as soon as you can get people to
understand
they had to remove themselves from those
scenarios the better off that it was
going to be for every single person that
was inside of that Trooper inside of
that platoon
so
2019 you decide you're gonna get out yep
you have a freaking awesome career
you're living the dream you've had
incredible deployments you've had all
kinds of autonomy you've got a great
reputation you're running training
what's going on why you decide to get
out
um family so at the time five kids
um and it was kind of a combination of
things so that's all I ever wanted to do
was be a seal and I was having the best
time of my life like every single
diploma every single tour was my
favorite tour I was just genuinely loved
being a part of that Community I love
putting on the uniform I loved being
around the people that you have the
opportunity to be around when you're in
that Community it's unlike anywhere else
in the world and
as I started to realize the impact that
some of those things were going to have
on my family it shifted my perspective
from being I don't even know if I would
call it selfish because my wife never
complained about it my wife is the best
human being on the planet and you know
she's she's one of eight which kind of
helps probably in understanding that
everything's not about you so she was
fully supportive of the career she to
hear her tell it she knew that a Sean
inside the seal platoon or inside the
seal Community was going to be a very
fulfilled and happy Sean which would
Translate to a very good and fulfilled
husband and a very good and fulfilled
father even if that time that I was home
was minimal the time that I was going to
be home I was going to be fully invested
because I was just on cloud nine the
entire time
you get through with the trade at tour I
was very young
maybe not age-wise but uh time wise I
finished that tour and I was at like 11
and a half years in the military
so I start to look at the next portion
of my career and again I would love to
do the next nine years even though I'm
not going to be with the guys even
though I'm going to be in some staff
positions hopefully a commanding officer
tour thrown in there towards the tail
end I would just still love to be in the
community but when I looked at
where my family was going to be during
those tours it changed my math up a bit
and if you remember I said my commanding
officer when I was a troop Commander was
phenomenal he was phenomenal at
everything including just being a mentor
on life too he was the first guy that
sat me down
and walked me through the rest of my
career where I wanted to be and not just
from a career standpoint he made me sit
down with a sheet of paper like this and
put where I wanted my next five tours to
be and then he made me write down
beneath every single one of those tours
the ages my kids would be when I did
that that hurt that hurt a lot I mean
sorry commanding officer but that might
be the reason I'm not in the community
anymore but thank you for prioritizing
me but uh
when I looked at the fact that my oldest
son Ronan was going to be 18 years old
when I hit 20. that hurt
because what that means is now that I
could finally be there every day
involved in his life he's gone he's out
the door to college doing great things
hopefully
enlisting or going into the community no
pressure son uh
but that was a start that was kind of
like a slap in the face of oh shoot man
like I've got
one chance of this at this father thing
and like you said I had a great career I
had a lot of fun I had some really
unique opportunities and it just became
apparent to me that I needed to spend
the rest of the this portion of my life
focused on my family and not necessarily
on myself that being said it's not like
I came to this decision overnight I
wrestled with this thing for a very very
long time because I didn't necessarily
know what I was going to do uh on the
outside
um I knew I loved the job I also knew
that people in the community had been
looking out for me and they had been
giving me these very unique
opportunities because they wanted me to
be in the community long term and that
means a lot to me when I look at your
troop Commander when you were a platoon
Commander was my boss multiple times
including when I was running the
training command and he was phenomenal
so I had to tell this person who hand
selected me to go and run this training
command I had to tell him that I was not
going to be in the community anymore and
I know for a fact that he invested a lot
of his personal time in me and that that
carries a lot of weight you know the
fact that people poured their time and
their effort and their mentorship into
me I didn't I didn't take that lightly
but it basically just came down to hey
it's either the community or it's spend
time with the family and family is
always going to win out on that one and
I will say this when I did have that
conversation he was awesome about it he
was fully support he busted my chops a
little bit at first of course but he was
fully supportive of it and the community
was fully supportive of that decision
which made it easier for me going out of
the community knowing that I didn't burn
Bridges knowing that I had a lot of
people you know still rooting for me
yeah that's uh that's a tough one yeah
there's not a that goes by that I
don't wish I was still in there but then
I'm at home with my kids yeah I get to
you know coach boxing in the town that I
live in and my son comes to it I get to
drop them off every day I get to pick
them up most every day I get to go to
all their games I get to go to all their
events and none of that stuff will be
possible if I was still in yep and then
so what'd you do once you got out yes
when you went to agoras it is and now
you know you and I had already had the
conversation about Echelon front and uh
I was going to do that and then so
rewind back to officer candidate school
I told you too my my best buddies uh I
met an officer candidate school and then
we went through the the selection
together had some tours together well
one of these guys got out a little bit
earlier than I did and him and another
seal who was a a lifelong buddy of his
started a it's construction technology
which is not two things that typically
go together but it's a construction
technology company and he wanted me to
come on board with him and be basically
help him start it up and run it and I
was already in conversation with you and
you know Echelon front's awesome and I
was like this job is sounds amazing in
the team like just look at who's on the
team it's fun it's basically like being
in a seal platoon again uh so I was all
on board and then I I called you and I
said hey I've got this other opportunity
to do this and
I don't even think I'm paraphrasing I
think this is literally what you said
which is you would be stupid to not do
that uh you said go do that and I had
told you I was only going to give them
probably two years in that position
because we didn't want to be in
California when we wanted to move out
and you said go do that for two years
learn get some experience in the
civilian sector we're here when you want
to come onto the team
so I did that for two years was the CEO
for about the last year of that you know
there was no need for a CEO at first it
was like four of us trying to get stuff
done but that was a big learning
experience
and also just an awesome time an awesome
time to see a lot of the things that we
had learned in the community translate
directly to civilian life which there's
always questions about it right there's
always questions about does this stuff
that we learn in this very unique Niche
is it going to fit with the civilian
sector and the answer is yeah because
the common threat is people and people
are the same in the military as they are
in construction as they are in the tech
sphere they're the same
so you end up doing that for two years
great company by the way and what they
do is they build houses in a factory
they design everything they then they
build the houses in the factory in
pieces and they ship them out and you
have like a house in like two weeks
since it's done it's insane so agorus
check it out if you need to build a
house the the balls of these two dudes
to so how they came up with this was
they both built houses in Coronado and
one of them did the traditional let me
bring in a contractor design team and
one of them said hey it'll be quicker if
I do modular
and they were miserable experiences both
of them just freaking hated it and out
of that experience they both said well
let's just start this company with our
Focus being to literally change how the
United States builds homes
pretty lofty goal and I'm trying to put
myself in that mindset of what I would
have done if I had just built a house
and in Coronado and it was a painful
process I don't think I would have set
out to start a company to change the way
that America builds I think I would have
just said well that sucked and now I've
got a cool house in Coronado that I'm
I'm happy with but they started this
company uh it's killing it these guys
are phenomenal and they're going to
continue to do amazing things and I'm
just thrilled to be a part of the team
and it's interesting you said you know
technology and construction which
normally don't go together you're right
and you know these guys point out that
construction hasn't changed it hasn't
changed in America in like probably
50 60 years sure there's some there's
some advancements with like material
your material but also the way that you
know you can go you can have an iPad and
you can see what the drawings are and
you can kind of see some different
angles but still the same thing you're
still like got a guy out there swinging
a hammer you're building the whole thing
on site that's it that's what you're
doing and these guys have got it no
we're gonna build this thing in a
factory yeah it's going to be squared
away we're going to ship it out there
we're gonna get this thing put up I mean
it's
it's it's changing the way that we do
construction in the country so I'm sure
those guys are going to continue to
dominate
um you do that for a couple years and
then you move out to Virginia how did
you land in Virginia so again my wife's
one of eight so she's originally from
New Hampshire
her her dad was a undercover agent for a
customs for a long time so he was doing
a lot of stuff in Boston against the
Irish mob stuff like that so they they
chose to live in New Hampshire because
it's basically right across the border
he could commute in so uh of one by one
they all started kind of matriculating
down to this town I don't know if I even
want to say the name of the town because
I don't know how many more people I want
coming to live there but it's an awesome
town in Virginia and they all started to
come down there and move into that town
and it just became kind of the the mecca
of our family so it was an easy decision
for us my wife would probably say it was
an easy decision because I drugged my
feet for a long time but when we finally
made the decision uh grandparents are
there uncles and answer their cousins
are there the family is there so we
moved out there we've got uh 60 Acres
out there run a small farm kids get to
go to school with their cousins they get
to see their family every single day of
the year and it's all the things that
advantages of San Diego yeah there's
awesome things that happen in San Diego
things that weren't in San Diego for us
was we're never having 60 Acres and uh
we had no family aside from my my sister
who's a trainer for an SW she's the only
family that we had here so it was an
easy decision to move out there and so
then we transitioned you into into
Echelon front as this was happening like
literally I stepped out of agorus one
day and was on board with Echelon front
the next day how do you like Castle on
front
what's not to like about it you know
it's awesome everything about it the
team is phenomenal uh the work getting
to go around and meet
awesome Americans and talk to them about
some of the issues that they're facing
talking to them about how to be more
effective leaders in their work life in
their personal life is ridiculously
rewarding ridiculously rewarding and you
see the difference that it makes in
someone's life when they decide to stop
pointing fingers when they decide to
stop blaming other people for problems
and they decide to actually do something
about those problems it's huge and you
you go and work with these companies and
all kinds of different sectors of the
economy right everything you could
possibly imagine and a lot of times when
we get brought in it's because there's a
change in leadership and new leaders
came in and they realized that maybe
things weren't done very effectively
from a leadership perspective before and
they want a fresh start and they'll
bring us in to kind of you know do some
training and talk about leadership and
we'll go and we'll see these these
people who are working hard jobs hard
our jobs factory jobs Oil Field
construction out there and then they're
just trying to provide for their family
and now you later on the heat and you
later on hard manual labor and you layer
on things that are inherently uh not the
safest occupations and now on top of
that you got to add the fact that they
got to deal with the freaking crappy
boss like that's a tough thing to see
and you know we'll come in and you see
new leadership comes in and they realize
that there's a problem and they want to
give a better environment for their
people and that's awesome you can come
in and you can actually make people's
lives better and that really is the what
leadership is all about is empowering
your people in every single area of
their life and it's cool to be able to
be a part of that for so many different
folks and also I get to learn from
from you from Echo from everyone on the
team like I'm not done learning about
leading just because I'm at Echelon
front now I get to work with awesome
people and every time I go on site with
someone I'm just listening and I'm
learning too and it's making me better
in my personal life and in my
professional life
when I first started like actually
teaching leadership in the teams like
this is what I'm teaching when I started
teaching the laws of combat when I
started teaching these things and I
started bringing that up the chain of
command we need to be teaching this
stuff
one of the arguments that I would use I
remember saying this to my Commodore at
the time I said Hey sir have you ever
heard of Hamburger University he's like
no what's that it's where it's in
Schaumburg Illinois and it's where if
you're going to be the manager of a
McDonald's you're gonna go to a
six-month school to learn about
leadership
and we I said sir we have guys that are
in a platoon that they're not getting
any leadership training they're they're
a platoon Commander they're a lpo
they're a platoon Chief and they've
never had any leadership training why is
that we need to train these guys and
this just goes so perfectly with what
happens in the civilian sector you're a
you're a guy on a construction site you
pour concrete and eventually someone
goes hey you're good at pouring concrete
now you're in charge of a team and now
you've LED that team for a while now
you're in charge of your alignment oh
you're good at doing your job as
alignment now you're gonna be in charge
of this team you're a sales person oh
you're a best sales person okay now
you're in charge of a sales team no one
gets trained in leadership and everyone
thinks oh well you are good at this job
as a plumber now you can lead a team
that's putting in you know a massive
plumbing job no it doesn't work that way
you actually have to learn how to lead
just like you have to learn to be a
plumber just like you have to learn
sales you have to learn how to lead and
that's really essentially
one of the most important reasons why
Echelon front exists because there's
people that get to CEO positions they've
never had a leadership training in their
life they've never done any leader
there's people that got went got how
many people have we taught leadership
that have their MBA from an Ivy League
school or some it's like they don't
learn anything about leadership and they
are so grateful when they realize oh
this is a skill that I can actually
learn and then we they can put it into
action almost immediately and then when
they get their whole team and they start
going oh I can educate all the people
that are leadership positions the svps
the VPS right on down the line to the
front line leaders right on down down
the line to the front line troops the
individual contributors they're learning
how to lead and then we get these
synergistic leadership situations
unfolding and it's just it's just so
rewarding to see these companies just
just step up their game across the board
so
that's awesome
it's all you've been a great addition to
the team I know it's been nothing but
outstanding feedback which is basically
what I always thought we were going to
get from you anyway so I remember once I
was like life didn't really know you
that well yeah and I was to like I said
hey you know this guy Sean glass and I
was like described was like hey man this
guy like he's just a stud he's very
articulate he's like he looks like you
know just like a Superman type character
that's going to be up there represent
National on front he's like life's like
you never say that about me
I'm like I'm sorry bro I was just trying
to sell you uh trying to sell try to
sell Sean but um yeah so that's been
awesome and then the latest Venture
you've gotten into which you dragged me
into which is I appreciate is uh Primal
beef how'd that how'd that start yeah so
that all started with the move uh out to
Virginia so we moved out to this area
it's right in the middle of the
Shenandoah Valley I mean it's kind of
paradise we're we've got the Blue Ridge
Mountains on the right side the Blue
Ridge Mountains on the left side the
Shenandoah River Runs right through the
middle of our town and it is
I don't even know if it's arguable that
it's the probably the most Lush region
in America uh and when we got there
again five kids got a lot of need to
feed those five kids uh we bought a cow
from a farmer that lived in that town
and I had the first bite of steak from
that cow and I looked at my wife who
always sits to my left at the dinner
table and I said this is hands down the
best steak I've ever had in my entire
life and because we have five kids and
we eat a lot of beef we went through
that cow pretty quickly and then we
ordered another cow
and it was from the same farmer and it
was phenomenal the exact same and it
really got my my wheels turning because
I'm like well people don't have access
to this most Americans cannot do what
I'm doing most Americans do not live
next to this farmer who is one blessed
enough to live in the Shenandoah Valley
where those cattle are grazing the
greenest pastures of all time and two
they don't have
access to get that thing and put it on
their plate every single night and to me
that just seemed kind of almost like
Un-American and I reached out to my
brother who lives in that Hometown my
buddy Paul who's a Rancher and then I
reached out to you and just said hey
here's here's what I'm thinking what do
you think about this and you know
gratefully you were you were on board
and then we started started the
mechanisms of building everything out
that we needed and uh we officially went
live early August with Primal beef and
all the feedback so far has just been
incredible and there's when people think
of
beef they don't typically think of
Virginia
they think a police is like Montana
Colorado Texas
there's so much beef that's produced in
Virginia the reason people don't
typically associate with that is it's
processing so all of the processing that
goes on for American beef is in the
midwest so cattle are getting raised in
Virginia historically and they're
getting shipped out to these processing
facilities and holding yards
historically right in the Midwest and
then they're just getting mixed in the
shuffle with all this other beef
but the fact is there's so many
advantages to beef that's raised in the
Shenandoah Valley that other places in
the country just don't have the
Chesapeake Watershed is right there and
it runs way Inland and it creates this
insane amount of ability for things to
just grow and Thrive inside of the
Shenandoah Valley region and you you
could you pair that with this little
micro climate that happens because
you've got the Blue Ridge Mountains on
both sides and the river running right
through and those pastures will grow
everything all these native grasses are
growing right there and that's what
these cows are eating on a day-to-day
basis and they're not having to work for
it they're not having to move three
miles to go find the next bite of grass
it's literally right in front of their
faces and you know you listen to you
read accounts of these explorers when
they first
these Western explorers when they first
made their way down into the Shenandoah
Valley and they're talking about riding
on Horseback through fields of grass
where the grass is so tall that it's
touching their shoulders as they're
going through there that doesn't happen
other parts of the country that's only
right there in this area and when you
talk about
what makes quality beef it really kind
of comes down to three things how
they're raised
what they're finished on and we'll talk
about finishing what that means and then
how they're processed the the Final Cuts
what does that look like so the
advantages for where we are is they're
grazing the greenest pastures in the
United States of America hands down all
these different Native grasses that are
just adding you know nutrient density to
the meat tenderness to the meat and
again they're not having to work for it
and because they're not having to work
for it they're not moving you know three
acres four acres three miles a day to go
find the next shrub to chew on that
translates directly to the quality of
the beef and all of our cattle come from
one Farm
all of our cattle come from one farm and
that is not something that you're going
to find most any other place that you're
trying to find beef in America you walk
into a grocery store zero percent chance
you know where that beef came from
there's a chance that beef's not even
American there's a chance that there's a
large chance that beef came in from
overseas there's also a very large
chance that that cow is not even a beef
cow it's probably a dairy cow and it's
probably a dairy cow that is now no
longer productive for dairy operations
and they're gonna process it and they're
gonna sell it a steak
that's not what you get with Primal beef
you get American Black Angus beef that's
raised on one farm right inside the
Shenandoah Valley and what that
translates to is quality and consistency
so if you look at even some of these
other operations and I'm not bashing
them look man the more Americans that
are eating beef that comes from a farm
the better for the United States of
America so you look at a good ranches or
a butcher box or something like that
they're helping Farmers out they're
putting
beef from American Farms on people's
plates that's great but what they can't
offer is they can't offer consistency
because they're coming from different
forms so you might have a steak you
really like one box in the next box it's
not going to be the same steak we didn't
want that we wanted every single person
to know when they place an order with
Primal beef exactly what they're getting
and that is the fact that their first
bite is going to taste just like their
thousands bite because all the cattle
are raised the exact same way on the
exact same farm so the how they're
raised
that's the unique thing about where
where they're raised on this Farm in the
Shenandoah Valley the next piece is how
they're finished and there's different
methods of we're nerding out on cattle
here but let's go
I'm a freaking steak connoisseur as you
know yes and when you sent me the first
one I was like okay cool rib eye let me
see what's up I'm like oh I'm in let's
go
you want to close the deal with Jocko
send him a freaking Shenandoah Valley
nearby and let me go to town on that
thing I was like yo this is this is
special awesome awesome and that's
exactly what we want every single
person's experience to be uh and hey
every decision that we make as a company
is based on two factors what's best for
the animal and what's best for the
customer every single decision that we
make and the finishing process for a
catalyst typically there's two ways that
they're finished they're going to be
either grass-fed and grass finished
or they're going to be grass-fed and
then finished on a uh some type of grain
something like that corn
um barley something like that
how you finish it adds
different flavor profiles to the beef
right grass-fed grass finish is going to
taste very different than a grass-fed
and then grain finished animal and that
makes sense right they're eating
different different food sources so for
us the the farm that we work with that
we partner with all of our steak all of
our beef all of our cattle come from
they he has a very unique finishing
process that I really think translates
directly to why this beef is so good and
so different than any other beef that I
have one again they're grazing these
pastures that other cattle in America
just don't have access to that's the
biggest differentiator right there in
the Shenandoah Valley
then the finishing piece is they
continue to graze they continue to have
access to grass but now he supplements
it with uh distiller's grain that he
grows on his farm
and he upcycles which is a trendy word
he upcycles produce from these local
markets that are around our hometown so
he gets produce off of
you know the shelves from different
markets when they have to make room for
new produce and he gets all of these
fruits all of these vegetables with uh
the grain that's grown on his property
and he mixes all that up into a mash and
that's what the cattle are finished on
for about the last 180 to 200 days and
again they have access to plenty of
grass they're still eating grass that
entire time but it's that that really
lends that unique uh flavor to it that
you know extra marbling that Rich beef
flavor to it so there's the first two
factors right how the cattle are raised
and how the cattle are finished the
third factor which is just as important
is how the cattle are processed
and we partnered with a processing
facility out of Lynchburg Virginia which
is a couple hours from us called Seven
Hills abattoir and the reason that we
partnered with them is they are the best
in the business in my opinion they're
definitely the best on the Eastern
Seaboard they're doing things at no
other place is doing and one of the
things that they do is the the welfare
of the animal again is always our main
concern
so they put a lot of effort into
maintaining the welfare of the animal
all the way up until it's time for for
processing and that translates directly
to the quality of the beef and you know
as a hunter right if I put a bad shot on
an elk and that elk is stressed out
and that elk runs 700 meters and now all
of that adrenaline is coursing through
that Elks vein the stress level of that
animal it makes the meat profile
different it toughens that meat up it's
the same thing with cows you know a cow
that's lived a very stress-free life in
the Shenandoah Valley grazing pastures
and has a very stress-free process of
processing
it's going to translate directly into
the the flavor and the texture of that
beef the really unique thing that they
do which again is not normal in the
processing industry is they dry age
everything whole carcass so the entire
carcass is dry aged for a minimum of 14
days now we don't go overboard and do
like the 28 extreme 28 day extreme dry
aging I don't personally like that
profile in in beef the flavor profile so
14 days whole carcass is what's
happening during that 14 days is
everything is breaking down the meat is
getting tenderized all these enzymes are
breaking down the flavor is getting more
bold the beef flavor is getting more
bold the marbling is settling in all
these great things are happening
that's not normal most processing plants
do not do that and the reason they don't
do that is space
it takes a lot of space to dry age a
carcass and it takes a lot of space to
dry age
a carcass for 14 days and every day
they're adding to the number of
carcasses that they need to to dry age
because more beef is coming in and most
of these massive processing plants that
are out Midwest and other places they're
dealing with such large volume that they
can't do that so what they do is it's a
process called wet aging and wet aging
typically what that means is
the the uh animal is processed and then
they start cutting into the animal right
away the carcass right away and then
they take those individual Cuts they
vacuum seal them or cryo seal them and
then they put them on shelving units
where they can organize everything save
a lot of space and then the the
individual cuts of meat continue to
break down because they're sitting in a
in their own blood basically and the
blood acts as a enzyme basically that
breaks everything down you know wet
aging there's not a saying that there's
that's necessarily anything wrong with
that but I don't think it's anywhere
near as good as dry aging and the reason
people don't dry age is you have to have
space for it Seven Hills is not trying
to be the world's largest processing
plant they're trying to be the world's
best processing plant which is exactly
why we partner with them because
everything they do is designed to give
the customer the best finished product
that they possibly can so they're dry
aging the whole carcass and then all
these cuts are hand cut by butchers that
work at 7 Hills and this is it's an
intangible thing but it's something that
we really love about these guys is
they're investing in that local
community that processing plant was shut
down for like 30 years and they brought
it back to life and they're providing
jobs for people that have been down on
their luck in Lynchburg you know for the
past 10 15 years when the economy is
suffering they're giving them good
paying jobs they're teaching them a
skill and something that I really love
that they do is they also hire from a
work release program so people who are
just getting out of prison who made some
bad decisions in their life who no one
else is willing to give these people a
second chance Seven Hills is willing to
give them a second chance and they bring
these men in and to to hear them talk
about it it's like on day one they won't
even look at you they've just been kind
of so beat down by the system that
they've been in that they it's hard for
them to even make eye contact and then
they start to work with them they start
to give them a skill they start to teach
them how to be a butcher which is a
craft that is very quickly going away
and they're giving them value through
work and through employment and they see
this huge turnaround where now all of a
sudden they can hold conversations
they're fitting back into society and
they have a purpose and you know we just
went and sponsored the The Lumberjack
games down in uh near Lynchburg and I
got a chance to to meet some of these
guys some of these work release guys and
the pride that they take in their work
we were serving Burgers during this
event and one of the guys that was there
had just been out of prison for two
weeks and he was the guy that was doing
all the grind for us all of the burger
meat and this guy could not stop talking
to me about how much pride he took in
that meet I wouldn't put anything on
your plate that I wouldn't put on my
family's plate and he could he was so
proud of the opportunity that these guys
have given them so you know their
producing the best finished cuts on the
Eastern Seaboard and outside from that
they're doing something that nobody else
is willing to do which is give people a
second chance and it is a game changer
for those people so that's the three big
factors that really go into beefar how's
that beef raised where are they raised
what are they eating how are they
finished and how's that beef processed
and every single thing that we did every
decision that we made was based on
giving the customer the best possible
experience that they could possibly get
and that's what Primal beef is all about
is about giving Americans who don't have
access to farm raised beef who've never
had the opportunity to really experience
the difference in farm-raised beef in
putting that on their plates because
let's be honest
I sit down to dinner every single night
with my family no matter what's going on
some people do that some people don't do
that some people got much busier lives
than I'm living right now
if there's chicken on the plate
whole family might not be sitting down
together you put a stake on that plate
the whole family is sitting down
together and anytime that Primal beef
can play a hand in families coming
together at the dental dinner table and
breaking bread and serving some
farm-raised beef that's a victory for us
and that's what we're trying to achieve
with Primal beef
word
and the deal is the way it's set up is
you pretty much order
uh like a box full of exactly various
Cuts exactly whether it's ground whether
it's uh I just had hot dogs yesterday
um freaking legit so those are awesome
and then you get you know whatever some
get some New York get some rib eyes in
there
um it's just that's just outstanding and
there's a couple different like sizes of
boxes you can get yes and the the reason
that we went with the uh the structure
that the box method is just to give
people the best value that we can
possibly give them and also again it
goes back to the wanting to pay respect
to that animal we don't want anything to
go to waste on this animal so we
designed our boxes to where uh one cow
basically breaks down into a certain
number of boxes that we can then deliver
we're not worried about Cuts getting
wasted we're not worried about Cuts
getting lost we want every single uh cut
of beef that comes off of these animals
to go into the hands of Americans and
their families so we've got different
box options and we try to put some
variety in there but we also know people
like different stuff right so you're a
rib eye guy so guess what we got we got
a box that features the main cut and
there is rib eyes and that box is also
going to have some other good Cuts but
the staple of that box is going to be
rib eyes and then there's some ground
beef some burger patties some all beef
franks you like New York's drips there's
a box that features a very predominantly
New York strips you like fillets that's
your go to there's a box for you you
want just ground beef maybe you're a
crossfeed athlete that crushes two
pounds of ground beef a day which
buddies of mine that compete in CrossFit
Crush two pounds of ground beef a day we
got a box that's just ground beef that
you can Crush two pounds of every single
day and we'll be there for you I've kind
of getting fired up
hey I'll tell you what to do I had the
patties
bro that makes a burger game changer
right and it's so easy you just take
them out and you throw them right on the
grill right on the Traeger whatever and
you've got
the best burger you've ever had a couple
minutes later yeah so I'm a steak
connoisseur now but when I was a kid so
like my mom and dad both worked they
were School teachers my mom used to go
to the butcher shop and get shop and get
these boxes full of hamburger patties I
think there was 40 in there yeah so for
breakfast I would have a hamburger on a
English muffin for lunch I'd have a
hamburger on a piece of bread and for
dinner I'd have a hamburger on a bun
there you go breakfast lunch and dinner
I to this day I don't really like
breakfast foods but I'll have a
hamburger 24 7. but yeah the patties
coming out of that Primal beef box were
legit yeah I was gonna give some to Echo
but then I ate them yeah that makes
sense
so uh primalbeef.com is where you can
get in the game you can get I mean I
don't there's nothing else to say go to
primalbeef.com put your order in and
join the club yeah the last two things I
would say is look are we gonna be a
little bit more expensive than if you go
to the store and buy something off your
shelf the yes we are and we're not
trying to hide that fact but what you're
getting in return is you're getting
you're supporting American farmers
you're getting traceability where you
know that every single stake every
single burger every single cut that
comes out of that box was raised on the
exact same Farm in the exact same way
and that's going to translate to the
exact same experience every single time
you are serving Primal beef you're
supporting American processing
facilities that are doing good stuff and
the last thing that you're supporting
and this is uh something that we're
really proud of is we partnered with the
C4 foundation so Charlie Keating
teammate of ours he was killed on the
deployment before me in Iraq so we
turned over with Seal Team one right
after he was killed
his dad is a phenomenal human being and
when we started this company it was very
important to all of us to be able to
give back to the community that we were
involved in military community and
there's different ways you can do that
you know some companies give a
percentage there's nothing wrong with
that but we wanted
what we did to be a little bit more
tangible and a little bit more uh I
don't know meaningful is the right word
but impactful directly impactful did you
say tangible already I did quantify a
quantify it's like quantifiable I think
it's quantifiable qualified searching
for we wanted to make a direct impact on
service members life so I called up Mr
Keating III
and I told them what we had going on and
I said hey would you be interested in
partnering with us because what I would
like to do is every time we sell a box I
would like to donate a cut of beef
directly to a special operations Force
member and their families and he was all
about it he was all about it and what I
want to point out with that is we're not
playing games we're not hiding that cost
in a box that cost of that cut is coming
out of your pocket Jocko it's coming out
of my pocket is coming out of declan's
pocket and it's coming out of Paul's
pocket the four of us that started our
partners in Primal beef and every time
you order a box we donate a cut directly
to a special operations Force member and
their family so not only are you
supporting American Farms not only are
you supporting American Business not
only supporting your family with
farm-raised beef but you're also
supporting seals and their families
every single time you place an order
outstanding
primalbeef.com
does that get us up to speed are we up
to speed we good I mean I hit the heavy
bag this morning and I think now we're
up to speed uh
you're you're not on social media are
you no well Prime will be for Primal
beef is so Prime will be a for Primal
beef Prime beef.com
um Instagram and Twitter
Primal underscore beef underscore
Co
I don't know if you know this but Primal
beef Twitter is suspended right now I
will look into that I have no idea why I
don't know I'll call up Elon and find
out what's going on so I don't know
what's up with that but uh it's
suspended okay so we'll figure that out
yeah but Instagram Primal underscore
beef underscore Co
that's where we're at Echo Charles any
questions uh did you use the word
matriculating I did what does that mean
it'd be basically uh coming down if you
will okay
cook I like um
precipitating a little bit exactly I
would almost say they could be brother
and sister words precipitating would
kind of be up here and what you would
say is the precipitation right
eventually matriculated down okay all
right yeah so that was you guys okay all
right I got it that's good uh I want to
rewind a little bit to drown proofing
okay so when I was in fourth grade
elementary school by the way oh we did
drone proofing
and it was a very specific process what
is drown proofing in buds or in the SEAL
Teams what is ground proofing yeah it's
an evolution you go through in first
phase where it's meant to to get people
to be or actually really to test
people's comfortability in the water so
what they do is you stand on the pool
deck they tie your feet together you
have to put your hands behind your back
they tie your hands together and then
you have to jump into the pool and you
have to complete a series of different
events wait hands and feet hands and
feet and tied behind your back the first
thing if I remember correctly that you
have to complete is a five minute float
where you have to float at the top of
the water for five minutes with your
hands and your feet tied together sounds
easy some people don't float people that
go through buds tend to not float very
well so there's different things that
you have to do to maintain your calm and
to be able to float the next thing that
you have to do is you have to swim
underwater a certain number of laps back
back and forth in this 25 meter pool
with your hands and arms tied together
or when you say underwater no you can
take breaths you can take breasts
correct but you're mainly your
mainlander like submarining and then
coming up when you need to take a breath
uh and then the last thing that you have
to do and this is like a
20 or 30 minute Evolution wait so the
swim your hands and feet
everything's tired together okay don't
you you missed Bobby oh yeah Bob that's
the first thing the first thing you're
nine foot of water yeah and you go down
to the bottom kick off
and take a breath go back down to the
bottom and you do that for like 10
minutes yes 10 minutes and then you
float for five minutes and then you swim
50 yards and then you have to go down
you there's your mask your dive mask is
on the bottom of the pool nine feet you
got to go down and get your mask so you
get it in your teeth you bring it up and
then you gotta sit there and tread water
until the instructor tells you can go to
the side yeah and you got to carry your
mask to the side in your mouth and
that's the process that's the process
drown proof that's the process I will
tell you this I practice that in college
I practice that in buds before we did it
but never with my hands and feet
actually tied together
hold them together yeah you know so when
it came time I was like no big deal
the sensation of actually having your
feet and hands tied together vastly
different experience that makes sense
vastly different experience uh which one
is like what what uh what event or
whatever what's the hardest one the
swimming
ah well it depends on who you're talking
to like well for me yeah for me uh I was
a decent swimmer so I wasn't too
concerned about that but what's
frustrating was one of my buddies was a
uh butterfly swimmer in college at
Arizona State I believe so as I'm trying
to just survive and swim across the pool
I'm literally watching him like a
porpoise fluttering through the water
yeah like it's no big deal gracefully
man the hardest part for me for that was
floating I don't float and it's all
about giant breath in and then just try
to hold it as long as you can quick
exhale another giant breath in the
secret to floating is you gotta have air
in your lungs as much as you can get in
there what was your hardest one for
drone out of those yeah uh yeah probably
just the floating yeah the floating
because you're the same thing like huge
breath hold it for as long as you can
and then you gotta like kind of kick to
the surface grab another breath and bro
what about like Remy like at a lake when
you're for what do you call it negative
negative Point whatever when you think
you gotta
he was probably like a little bit closer
to treading and probably a little bit
more out of oxygen probably just it was
probably a little bit harder really yeah
they like it was not loving the drum
proof and I can just about guarantee you
that yes sir I understand it's a little
bit different than my fourth grade drone
proofing yeah but yeah interesting
nonetheless good Evolution cool good to
see you again bro you as well man always
a pleasure
Sean any closing thoughts from you
I think we just about covered everything
just thankful to be here thankful to be
on the team
right on man awesome uh well thanks for
coming out man and thanks for sharing
your Lessons Learned obviously
uh thanks for what you did in the teams
in for the Navy for the nation and
thanks for what you're continuing to do
raising your family Echelon front
spreading the word and now Primal beef
getting after it helping America
eat and live better
thanks bro much appreciated
and with that Sean glass has
left the building
so there you go yeah a little bit of
getting after it
get that
get some of that steak protein
however sometimes you always don't have
that steak available no you know what I
mean sometimes you're going around the
door yes you know what I mean those you
need protein literally that was me today
so I did squats today you're welcome and
but I was running I was right uh you
know what he called press for time I was
pressed for time and has some leftover
steak that was uh what do you call them
strips like I cut them last night they
were from last night left over
but I cut them in strips boom right
had them in the fridge or whatever so I
was like freaking pressed for time just
throw them in the microwave real quick
so I'm like trying to eat them or
whatever after they came out of the
microwave and I'm like bro I'm not gonna
finish this whole thing right now like I
gotta go see what I'm saying so I ate a
few which was in my estimate about
10 to 15 grams of protein worth a steak
which is not that much for steak because
steak especially post squats yes
bro just grab the milk Easy Money
literally on the way out it won't fridge
out like didn't even like stop like the
water
no no I like how you just amazing well
if you put yourself in the situation I'd
be amazed too just you'd be amazed how
little time it was taken yeah
bro I'm telling you didn't even stop it
took more time for me to throw the other
one in the microwave see I'm saying yeah
yeah for sure so yeah no steak no
worries hey go energy drink of which
I've had to because I didn't know that
was gonna be a four hour podcast yeah
but it was because Sean glass was
talking about some good stuff you know
what I mean uh I'm too deep right now
the thing is what should we be calling
Jocko go a clean energy drink a healthy
energy drink a good for you energy drink
like what should we be calling it
because it's not a freaking normal
energy drink yeah yep I like I've always
liked clean the word clean energy drink
I like that or whatever here's the
here's the question clean I think a lot
of people throw out there
right A lot of people be throwing that
out there clean this clean that but it
doesn't actually have meaning also the
problem with healthy is people here
healthy and they think oh it's going to
taste like crap basically that's
literally like what the feeling it gives
you yeah it gives you that feeling but I
guess clean is the what we're gonna do I
like it I like clean do people recognize
what that means though do they do they
recognize that that means healthy
because let's face it some other energy
drinks have claimed to be clean they're
not clean yeah I don't know you see what
I'm saying I do seriously I know this
though if you or if someone's saying hey
like man this this month I'm eating
clean it it gives me and this is just
the feeling right where it's like
they're not I don't get the same feeling
as if they say I'm on a diet like when
they say that that that's the same as
healthy right the feeling of uh sure
you're probably eating healthy but it's
probably not tasty it's not that
enjoyable but when they say I'm eating
clean I'm thinking oh you're you're
eating the good stuff you know like the
steak the freaking chicken with the
perfect recipe I'm saying you're just
not eating BS you see what I'm saying
you're not eating fast food you're not
eating a bunch of like cookies and ice
cream stuff like this you see what I'm
saying that's that's the impression so
maybe we'll go with clean get a clean
energy drink yep Get It Go
get that get it all jocklefuel.com get
hydrate get greens get Mulk what we just
talked about the protein shake Krill
super Krill joint Warfare just get it
just go get it chocolate fuel dock.com
by the way aphes you can get if you're
in the military you can get it at AAFES
you get a Hannaford you can get a
vitamin shop GNC's got the drinks in
there go to GNC and grab some ghosts
that's a good plan actually did you hear
me sniffling a little bit yes what was
that okay so I felt myself you were
crying no I wasn't crying not this time
but so I've been like a colder bro it's
been a while since you cried on the
podcast thank you for you know pointing
that on everything but nonetheless a
sickness like a cold has been kind of
starting to develop okay in my body
okay so I'm like all right boom cold war
three a day yeah cold war Cold War Cold
War bruh this cold like kind of emerged
and yeah it wasn't even a cold it didn't
even develop into a cold it developed
into just what you heard just to sniffle
that's it and I don't even have sniffer
right now it was just like a like a
momentary sniffle like a temporary
sniffle no that time you broke down
that was good
then I realized I had to give you like a
heads up like in the future right kind
of your phone yeah yeah so we'll watch
that thank you nonetheless Cold War
freaking did the job again super
reliably by the way yep it's powered
it's powerful the thing is this is how
you know when when a sickness was
successful if you gotta miss a workout
or miss school or miss work yeah that's
so you know like that was a successful
sickness yeah this one's not even close
yeah didn't you I didn't even consider
should I work out there I never
considered that it wasn't even a thing
enough for me to for considerations I'm
saying Cold War all day
vitamin shop Hannaford's Dash stores
wake Fern ShopRite HEB down in Texas
thank you Meyer in the midwest thank you
Harris Teeter Lifetime Fitness Shields
and by the way small gyms you got a
CrossFit gym you've got a Jiu Jitsu
Academy you want to sell jungle fuel
email JF sales.com that's what we're
doing or go to jockoffield.com get the
stuff that you need
just had the Pre-Workout come out today
it's a little bit psycho a little bit
it's a lot of business it's a lot of
it's like but so it's psycho I told you
I quit pre-workout like maybe three
realistic like two three years ago okay
because I was like you know pre-workout
like before this pre-workout pre-workout
is the kind of like hey man let's face
it I just need to get freaking amped up
I don't care the cost right now I just
gotta get amped up and I need the pump
and which I get it man because I was
there but if you remember the work the
Pre-Workout back when they first
exploded onto scene one was called no
dash explode one was called jacked with
the e was a backwards three or three or
I don't know whatever right so it was
like yeah they're things their thing but
bro no I was like but you don't even
know what's in that thing like you're
well it's probably some nefarious things
in that thing so I was like bro after a
while I'm like bro I'm literally gonna
kill myself because you know your
tolerance goes up and then you're taking
two scoops and like all this stuff so I
stopped stopped the Pre-Workout and then
for two years so I was like okay was a
pre-workout you know he's not putting no
freaking weirdo stuff in there so at
least I'm gonna be healthy so let's get
back on the train hell yeah get that
pump
bro I took like half a scoop yeah put it
in while we're filming that video by the
way half Square I put it in brought two
sips I'll say bro I feel the the
tinglingness
I was all sensitive to it plus it was
like
that's kind of heavy you know it's
psycho it's psycho I was even while
we were filming like there's edits of me
like I'm going psycho in there yes you
are I'm like go like yeah we filmed we
captured it I guess I needed it for like
the moment right I had to get into
character but I was in character I was
going psycho yep you know what I mean
yeah they're really cool there you go
jogofuel.com go check it out it's true
also
origin USA boom I swear we're getting
our geese uh so
we just I just uh so Carlos Mendes our
boy loss yeah hell yeah he sends me a
picture of two Origin geese Nano Pearl
weave is that what it's called yeah Nano
nanopro wait why did he send you
pictures of two keys because he got just
got two keys one black one one white no
big deal he's like bro
I'm telling you it's got his brown belt
right uh I'm I don't know okay I don't
see freaking is on that path man I'm
telling you inappropriately has origin
keys because bruh if you have a Geon you
don't have the origin one you're kind of
like hey look maybe ignorance is bliss I
don't know maybe no it's not Bliss
honestly if you've had an orange it's
not blessed yeah but you wouldn't be
ignorant anymore but it's still not
Bliss because you still never in my life
did I go oh this feels good to put on it
was like one of those crappy old cops
that's true come on dude you that was
never Bliss yeah no it's no it was just
like tolerable you see insane but now
it's like
get Jeans by the way Winter's coming get
a hoodie you need a hoodie for winter or
the black wash jeans out
the Delta security the black one yeah
yeah the black black the other out yep
that's not what they call it black wash
I think it's called black it's just
black coloring the color see I don't
know the terms but the black ones are
out and I got one so boom oh wait you
got it I don't have any sorry yeah
all right so there you go origin you
guys get all your American made stuff
speaking of American made get some
Primal beef Primal beef.com you heard
the deal I don't think anyone's ever
convinced me more to even eat more steak
and getting me all hungry yeah and plus
did you eat today
I just ate those those little strips of
steak
I just had a milk but other than that it
was a lean morning oh no wait I take it
back I did I also have a milk when I
rushed out the door this morning I had a
chocolate yep yeah but the thing about
milk is like I'd water them maybe
everybody's different but oh and had a
banana too by the way but it after I
drink it like literally 30 minutes later
like it's not like I'm still full maybe
like 45 minutes I'm not still full some
people different but um maybe right
after workout too maybe that had
something to do with it so I'm still
hungry and then Sean glass talking about
all this grass fed fruit finished and
like all this stuff and the quality and
the development of the flavor like all
this stuff steak Ribeyes all this stuff
I was not like singing like I was like
seeing steaks in my head
okay I'm gonna go home and have one by
the way uh so there you go
primalbeef.com check that out
jackalstore.com yes sir but some um some
good stuff with chocolate store by the
way so shirt Locker boom we're rolling
got a new design I got one I was gonna I
was gonna uh send it to you but I don't
know I didn't it's like a uh is there a
point to that story yeah
yeah you know sometimes you'll like I
think oh he'll probably like this one
yeah and I'll send it okay what is it
it's like yeah but after a while I'm
like maybe like maybe okay so it's like
a you know the TNC surf the yin yang yep
right it's that but one of them has you
facing this way and then one of them has
the eagle facing the other way right the
what an eagle American bald eagle okay
so do you know what that is for no I
have no idea bruh discipline and freedom
so I'm saying discipline is this way
going this way and then the other one is
freedom because the Eagles like Freedom
anyway see that's I'm glad I didn't say
what is it like a cartoon thing I don't
know a drawing art it's art we'll call
it art yeah yeah graphic graphic design
does it look like it could be a Harley
Davidson shirt because if you have like
an eagle and it's a photo and it does
not TNT it's like that yin yang thing
give me another symbol anyway you're
gonna have to see it to appreciate it
and guess what a bunch of people they're
gonna see it and I believe they're gonna
appreciate it all right man there you go
shirt it's called the shirt Locker if
you don't know shirt Locker it's on
Jocko store it's one of the things on
Jacob stores where you can get other
shirts just splin equals Freedom good
stand by to get some that's a good one
people like that one
um and also we have the shirt Locker
which is a new shirt every month
different designs one of them in which
is
the yin yang this clinicals Freedom sure
there's a bunch of other ones anyway
check it out chocolate store.com
subscribe to this podcast subscribe to
the Jocko underground subscribe to your
YouTube channel get psychological
warfare go to flipsidecanvas.com get
something cool to hang on your wall get
the books that we have I've written a
bunch of books get them especially the
kids books I should just talk about that
with Sean glass like he's all about he's
got five kids that have wore your kids
to them to the Bone right
also like he he we were talking about
Jiu Jitsu I was like the other Jiu Jitsu
you know somewhere around here he's like
no there's not I was like dude check it
out and he found one and now he's got
his just go train get your kids to wear
your kid books Mike and the dragons
about face by hackworth just get these
books uh Street Echelon front
we have a leadership consultant you
heard the kind of caliber of people that
we have at Echelon front Sean glass is
one of those people
we will help your company
get through their leadership issues and
turn them into leaders you probably
haven't gotten your leadership team
trained to be leaders you probably just
thought they could figure it out well
they can't they have to learn it oh I
guess you can figure out like you can
figure out how to play basketball you
can figure out how to play guitar but
think of how much you can figure out how
to do Jitsu but think about how much
extra time it takes
if some if you have to learn it yourself
as opposed to someone coming in and
saying hey let me just show you how to
do that let me show you where to put
your foot over there on that on that arm
lock
true so learn echelonfront.com we also
have online Training Academy extreme
ownership.com come on there and learn
these skills these are skills we want
you to learn these skills
that's my goal
is to teach as many people these
leadership skills as we possibly can
check it out please
extreme ownership.com that's the Online
Academy
also we have
if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help gold
star families
check out Mark Lee's mom mama Lee she's
got a charity organization it's
unbelievable what they do to help out
also you heard Sean mention the C4
Foundation you can check that out as
well outstanding organization and of
course Heroes and horses.org
where Micah Fink is taking our veterans
Into the Wilderness so they can
reconnect with their soul
and if you want to connect with us
Sean can be found only through Primal
with no social media for Sean legit
credit but now he's got to have Primal
beef Primal beef.com and Instagram and
Twitter I don't know why his Twitter was
on freaking shut down interest uh Primal
underscore beef underscore Co
Echo is that Echo Charles I'm at Jocko
just watch out for the algorithm just
just it's a monster it'll just grab you
and you'll just waste your life
that's what will happen
thanks once again to Sean glass
for everything you have done
for the nation for the Navy for the
teams thanks for what you're doing right
now at Echelon front with your family
and of course Primal beef
getting people fed with the good stuff
thank you and thanks to all our Armed
Forces out there on the front lines
protecting us and our way of life
from all enemies
foreign and domestic and thanks to our
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emt's dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service and all First Responders
thank you for protecting us and our
families here on the home front and to
everyone else out there
listen you get to decide
you get to decide what you do you get to
decide who you are you get to decide to
stay on the path that you get to decide
if you fall off it
you get to decide when and where you go
and when things are truly beyond your
control you get to decide how you will
respond to those things it's on you
so don't fall off the path don't fall
for short-term gratification think
strategic stay on the path and you do
that every day
by going out there
and getting after it and until next time
this is Echo and Jocko
out